e e
please take your seats we're about to
begin
okay good morning everyone and welcome
to science technology and energy for the
last Monday of January 2025 we'll begin
this morning as is our custom by all
rising and joining representative Rita
Matson as she leads us in the Pledge of
Allegiance
i al to the of the United States of
America and to the Republic for which
stands
indivisible andice for
all all right once again good morning
everyone I'm representative Michael Bose
chair of this committee and we're have a
full day of public hearings to get to
and we'll start those in just a moment
but first I wanted to bring the
committee up to date last week at this
time when we met uh I think I explained
or informed you that we had 22
bills to deal with well about three days
later that number jumped from 22 to
43 so we doubled the number of bills
that got assigned to us uh just last
week so we are going to have a very busy
month month
ahead I have tentatively scheduled all
the bills and we can actually finish all
the public hearings by the 3rd of March
according to the schedule I've put
together now that depends on the fact or
or the the the luck that we won't have
any days cancelled by snow or that um
there won't be some other kind
of event emergency or whatever that
prevents us from meeting but
if uh if all goes well we should be able
to finish public hearings on all the
bills by the 3D of March the first
Monday of March we will sprinkle in some
executive sessions along the way
to get bills done and on their way to
the
clerk we will have an executive session
tomorrow morning on three bills bills
two of which we're hearing today I
believe and uh that will give us a total
of six bills on the house calendar for
the first session of 2025 2026 which
will be Thursday February
6th does anyone have any questions about
uh our status going forward seeing none
okay let's open a public hearing then I
open the public hearing on on House Bill
189 and call to
the testimony table Vice chair
representative Doug Thomas the prime
sponsor of House Bill 189 which defines
clean energy and the department of
Energy's 10-year estate energy strategy
to include new technology smallscale
nuclear energy renewable energy and fuel
diversity and removing references to the
Energy Efficiency and sustainable energy
board representative
Thomas uh thank you uh Mr chairman good
morning uh to you and to members of
science technology and energy uh my name
is representative Doug Thomas I
represent Rockingham County 16 which is
Londoner this bill is very simple uh the
sole purpose of this bill is to include
nuclear in the definition of clean
energy uh this is something that many
states have already done
uh I've already checked and seen that
even the states of New York and Colorado
have legisl legislation pending to
include nuclear technology in their in
their version definition of uh clean
energy so it's time that New Hampshire
does that as well and one of the reasons
why we want to do this uh obviously uh
nuclear energy does not emit any CO2
emissions but the other reason is to
give notice to potential investors that
New Hampshire is open uh the market is
open to any type of nuclear technology
that they may seem fit to come in here
and we want to make sure that we want
them to know this and we want to make
sure that there are no barriers that
would prevent any marketing company from
coming in here and seeing if they can do
business here involving the new type of
nuclear technology so with that said um
that would have been all I had to say
except that uh when I went to the OS and
the lawyer to tell them my goal
they decided to put the definition of
clean energy
into section one chapter 21 of the state
rsas which is a huge compilation of
General definitions of various things
and so the definition of clean energy
was put into a new added uh chapter
55 which would be easy to find the
follows chapter 54 which is a definition
of gender identity uh but you can see
how everything mixes in there in doing
so and I had a conversation with the
Department of of energy we discovered
that inadvertently they had combined
nuclear and fuel diversity under the
definition of clean energy which was not
my original intent so I have prepared an
amendment it's um amendment number
uh
202-7710 12 P colon 7 C where uh it will
say clean energy and fuel diversity so
as to not mix the two
together uh with that being said that
was the sole purpose of this bill uh
I'll answer questions involving that I'm
done thank you representative questions
for the representative representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman thank
you for taking my question uh just a
clarification when you say small scale
nuclear I don't really how that's
defined are you talking about smrs here
small modular reactors or is it anything
of any size that's small and what how do
you define small well my my uh thought
was looking at the Practical aspects of
it that small scale nuclear technology
is the new nuclear technology of the
future and that's what I felt was a
reasonable uh thing to put into the
definition of clean energy um that's
because you know practically speaking I
don't think we're going to be doing any
large scale like Seabrook again followup
follow up yeah the reason I bring it up
because with smrs you could be looking
at let's just say uh a 10 megawatt uh
plant so that's going to be small scale
but you can also look at 10 megawatts
times five in the same location which
would be is that small scale I'm just
not sure we're defining the term clear
enough to say small scale should be you
know less than 100 megawatts uh if it's
if it's you're talking about smrs were
going to be manufactured remotely for
the most part so you might have a site
where they put in two five megawatt
plants and then five years later they
decide let's put in three more does that
then not become a small scale I just
think we need to tone Define that a
little bit better what wasn't my
intention to go to that much detail my
intention was just to include nuclear
under the definition of clean energy
representative Wendy Thomas thank you uh
Mr chair
um nuclear waste is anything but clean
um in our field trip to seab Brook we
saw they have an entire building to
house spent nuclear waste so how is this
addressed under your definition of clean
energy again it was only to put the fact
that nuclear is clean energy the EU has
included nuclear in their definition of
clean energy so has so have many other
countries uh we this does not speak to
how we store it uh which incidentally
the storage of nuclear waste at Seabrook
is very small area very deep underground
but that's not the purpose of this bill
this purpose of the bill was just to put
nuclear as a definition of clean energy
so that when we talk about clean energy
it doesn't omit nuclear as potential
possibilities how we handle it how we
store it would be matter for another
business
followup sorry I I saw your arm
representative McGee and thought it was
her raising her hand again actually
representative Kaplan had his his hand
up
first thank you Mr chair I just have a
quick question um and I appreciate the
amendment I I think that's a a wise
Amendment uh does the term clean energy
occur in any of the other statutes
relating to you know energy or utilities
I mean I know we have renewable energy
like as we have the renewable energy
standard and stuff but does the term
clean energy is there any other program
associated with that definition that you
know
of uh there
are sprinkled throughout the
rsas references to something being clean
energy um for a particular program but
nowhere in the rsas is there a
definition uh and that's why I was
spitting uh this bill so because of that
that's why this bill was submitted but
there are but there are our references
to programs when they speak of say
renewable as clean energy that's how
it's addressed there but it's not really
defined until this bill came
along okay representative McGee thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr Vice chair
for taking my uh
question um I'm wondering if we're going
to be defining clean energy in that list
I mean I went and looked it up it's
really general terms um of statutory
construction related to statutory
construction so I'm not sure if it is
appropriate for it to be there but if OS
thinks that that's a good place for
definitions I'm wondering if we could
Define clean energy as non-greenhouse
gas emitting sources of energy so that
we're clear we're not identifying
individuals we're not limiting it in
terms of future Technologies but we're
simply saying that if it's not
contributing to the problem of
greenhouse gases in the atmosphere that
we would consider it clean for those
purposes we don't have to call out
specific
Technologies um and maybe if we if we
could come to an agreement on what the
definition should be then it would be
you know um easier for anybody reading
the statute to understand what we meant
because clean energy doesn't appear to
be defined anywhere else and it looks
like this bill is trying to put a
definition
there well the uh what the impetus
behind this was in the 12p chapter which
is comes under the uh energy 10 years
strategy plan they had a subsection in
there that spoke about um clean
energy uh such as Renewables and then
they and then they added uh fuel
diversity so my intent was to add
nuclear to that portion so we so nuclear
would be included for in investors to
see but when I spoke to the lawyer at at
OS and asked me what was my intent I
said my intent was just to include
nuclear as clean energy I wasn't
thinking about any other definition I
just wanted to include nuclear in there
that's when he decided to put it up into
you know chapter 55 of chapter 21 I
guess uh so any additional definition I
guess you could come forward with W with
an idea and we can certainly discuss
it so just to to put a button on it or a
pin on it I don't know what what the
right metaphor is
um if we're defining clean energy my
opinion is we should and I'm a
co-sponsor on this it should be as broad
as possible and then when it comes to
amending 12 p7 A1C which is um where the
list is of what's included um I don't
have any problem uh having clean energy
and fuel diversity listed there and if
clean energy is defined as
non-greenhouse gas emitting sources of
energy then it would include nuclear and
um by definition um and it would be in
the list for the 10-year strategy report
that we would want anything in that
category to be reported on when the
10-year strategy report comes out so
you're you're looking to list it
explicitly and I'm saying does it make
sense if we're defining what clean
energy is for the state that we um put
in a category defining what clean energy
is so that everything that fits that
description is then included like I said
it's open for discussion
yes representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair uh
uh just making an observation of the
recommendation that the representative
McGee made saying uh Define clean as
non- greenhouse gas
emitting um water vapor is the most
ubiquitous greenhouse gas
Beyond carbon by factor of 50 to 100 so
uh if one was uh using hydrogen as a
fuel and hydrogen has been proposed as a
uh source of of a a fuel to be generated
by power plants or windmills when when
their load is not being uh fully
utilized it's it's an ancillary uh
byproduct that could be made because it
could be used as a fuel D
afterwards that concept of
non-greenhouse gas emitting does would
not work I think you're much better off
identifying nuclear as a clear um clean
fuel source right up
front
noted representative schneller has a
question thank you chairman fos um so
all you're trying to do is simply add
this to the definition of clean energy
you're not trying to sort of broaden the
definition of how we recognize clean
energy it's very narrow very simple
You're simply adding nuclear as clean is
that correct that that was my original
intention yes thank
you okay seeing no further questions I
would oops representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um you just stated
that the intent was to Define nuclear en
energy however in your testimony you
said that the intent was to invite
nuclear energy technology to New
Hampshire and let them know we're open
for business so what is the intent of
this Bill thank
you well you're correct uh the my intent
was to put nuclear under clean energy
because that's where it belongs and as a
result of doing that for the state
investors will look at those rsas and
see that oh they admit they accept ccept
that nuclear energy is part of clean
energy and therefore they're not adverse
to it should we choose to do business in
the State uh with involving nuclear
energy so I would say that my intent was
to Define it put nuclear in there and as
a result it would open the door to for
people to see that we are open to having
some form of clean nuclear energy come
into the state thank
you representative McGee this is just on
forum again we are adding a definition
for clean energy under the statutory
construction list of you know laws
relating to how we govern the state so
uh it's a definitional framework and the
way this bill would ask the language to
be added the definition in statutory uh
construction for clean energy would be
the words clean energy shall include
smallscale nuclear and renew rable
energy um it's a definition of clean
energy so um we're really trying to say
what does the term
mean and if we're just naming
technologies that are included rather
than the definition of clean energy I I
think it's not at the right level for us
to
be putting it in that list I don't I
don't think it's an appropriate
definition because it doesn't doesn't
cover us for future Technologies um and
future things that are not spelled out
in the list I think we should be
defining what clean energy
is
noted okay thank you see no further
questions I want to thank
representative Vice chair Thomas for
introducing this legislation and call
next on the New Hampshire Public
Utilities Commission Alex
spidel good morning to the Pu I see
you're all here this morning uh yes good
morning Mr chairman I just wanted to
offer some brief remarks in support of
this bill uh from the puc regardless of
the ins and outs of how the technical
language will be worked out and where
it'll end up um PC thinks it's a
laudable goal to support the concept of
uh all of the above energy approach in
New Hampshire including nuclear uh that
has been a principle of our state energy
policy since at least the time of
Governor Lynch so we just wanted to
offer our general overall support for
this bill um and that would be all
unless there's follow-up
questions questions for Mr
spidel representing the
commission seeing none thank you
representative Corman thought of one
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
spidel for taking my question uh so when
you say all of the above does that
really mean all of the above like any
energy Source well I would offer this in
so far as our neighbors especially in
Southern New England uh are calling on a
rapidly expanding capacity obligation we
heard from the iso about 73 GW and so we
were roughing out the math that would be
equivalent to about 80 Seabrook nuclear
power plants uh New Hampshire is unique
in so far as we are advocating and have
advocated for as long as I've been
around again since the time of Governor
Lyn
for uh the capability to expand our
energy generation to serve this expanded
load need so uh we're a lonely voice
right now in the regional grid and I
think it's important for New Hampshire
to remind everyone out there that uh if
you want to radically expand your energy
diet you need to expand your energy
generation capability as well and so
nuclear being in the mix small nuclear
is indicated by uh Vice chairman Thomas
could help in that
direction seeing no additional questions
I want to thank
you on behalf of the Pu for being here
this this morning thank you sir and next
we'll hear from Simon Warwick who is
here on behalf of
starcube which I believe is New
Hampshire's only nuclear
startup good morning and
welcome good good morning Mr chairman uh
members of the committee thank you very
much for allowing me the time to present
to you today on behalf of star cube um
where I'm head of growth starcube is a
new Portsmouth New Hampshire based um
Pioneer in the advanced nuclear industry
looking to design manufacture deploy and
operate Advanced nuclear um throughout
New England and maybe elsewhere too
Hampshire May stand at a critical
juncture in its energy policy having the
potential to become a net exporter of
electricity to the rest of New England
through strategic decision making the
foundation of this transformation May
lie in adopting Advanced nuclear energy
technologies that promise to bring
reliable and cost competitive
electricity generation to commercial
realization within the next decade with
informed policy decisions public and
private focus and investment
um in advanced nuclear technology New
Hampshire could transform its energy
sector into a leading provider of
reliable and costeffective
electricity these are not my words these
words are taken directly from the
commission to investigate the
implementation of Next Generation
nuclear reactor technology in New
Hampshire and I commend the participants
of that commission some of whom are
present today for their detailed
methodical and comprehensive examination
of this topic
at the federal level in the US nuclear
energy deployment framework document
published in November of last year it
states the US government explicitly
considers nuclear energy as a clean
energy source stating that nuclear power
delivers safe clean reliable and
affordable electricity to communities
Across the Nation and plays a critical
role in the nation's transition to a
clean energy economy and this
classification extended into several
important um laws firstly the bipartisan
infrastructure law of 2021 which
explicitly included nuclear power in its
definition of clean energy under
programs aimed at decarbonizing the
energy sector in the inflation reduction
Act of
2022 the law provides clean energy
production tax credits for nuclear power
nuclear energy is treated on par with
wind solar and other renewable sources
for its contribution to a carbon free
electricity
grid looking down at the state level as
representative Thomas mentioned Arizona
Connecticut Illinois Minnesota New
Jersey New York Ohio Pennsylvania
Virginia Washington Wyoming and most
recently Massachusetts in 2024 have
modified their definition of clean
energy to include nuclear
fision as a New Hampshire resident of
over 25 years and a representative of a
pioneering New Hampshire business I'm
committed like all in this room to the
advancement of the New Hampshire economy
the development of a skilled Workforce
that can
access advanced high-paying jobs and a
clean environment in which to raise our
families clean energy is key to this
vision and by adding this designation
into law we are Str strengthening the
New Hampshire advantage and continuing
to position the state as a leader in New
England's energy
landscape I'll take any questions
anybody might have thank you appreciate
you being here and I would like to
invite you to uh come back later in the
session when we have some spare time to
tell us more about your
company and if there are any questions
for this gentleman right now I'd remind
the members that the questions should be
about this bill not about starcube
representative Kaplan did you have
one yeah I suppose so I mean it is about
the bill uh in the sense that we are you
know trying to advaned uh nuclear energy
in our state and so I I I welcome uh the
gentleman coming in today and taking our
question this is just a question to
allay the fears of people who agree that
we need nuclear energy and in all of the
above strategy as I do but uh do have
concerns about the waste product that so
what is your pitch to people who are
concerned about the waste products uh
you know caused by nuclear energy
absolutely I understand um unlike carbon
emissions from fossil fuels which are
released into the atmosphere and cannot
be easily retrieved nuclear waste is
contained and
stored its volume is minuscule compared
to the waste and pollution generated by
fossil fuels that release toxins like
Mercury sulfur dioxide and particulate
Mass directly into the air and water
causing widespread
harm nuclear spent fuels is are securely
managed in regulated facilities ensuring
minimal risk to the environment and
human health advances in technology such
as fast reactors and reprocessing can
significantly reduce the volume and
toxicity of nuclear waste geological
repositories like finland's onalo
facility demonstrate that safe long-term
storage for for nuclear waste is
feasible the waste is isolated deep
underground far from ecosystems and
human
population representative Harrington has
a question more of a comment than
anything else I think when we're talking
about the waste people ought to
understand putting it in say minimals
kind of like what does that mean well if
you took one of these tables right here
that could contain 18 months worth of
spend fuel from seab Brook so the whole
40 years or even if it goes to 880 years
you could fit all the waste in this room
it's not that big of a problem people
overestimate that quite a bit thank you
I would I would add to that that um star
cube reactors being five 5 to 15
megawatts um our orders of magnitude
smaller than
sebr representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um I'm I'm sorry I didn't
get your name I just have that you're
the head of growth yeah Simon Warick
Simon all right thank you very much um
you right now you're the only nucle
nuclear private facility in New
Hampshire we're not a facility okay um
we are a business that is designing and
looking to manufacture Advanced uh
micronuclear rectors here in New
Hampshire thank you can I
continue thank you
um with the intent of this bill being to
essentially open doors for New Hampshire
to nuclear energy do you anticipate any
kind of oversaturation of this industry
in New Hampshire uh no I do not um uh as
has been said before especially I think
by representative Thomas
um as I'm going around the country and
indeed um other countries looking at
where star cube can make a difference
one of the first things that comes up is
sighting um not so much the technology
lots have been written about Advanced
nuclear and and it's different to
differences to traditional nucle clear
um there is a
huge need for increased power we all
recognize that but on the industrial
side not so much on the sort of microG
side not so much on the power generation
side I'm constantly receiving calls from
businesses who would like to use
Advanced nuclear to power things like
Bitcoin mining data centers
um uh using uh um process heat in their
manufacturing capabilities they don't
care where they site from a state point
of view they're looking for an
environment that welcomes them um where
they can do business defining uh nuclear
as clean energy helps in those
decision-making processes by those uh
entities our order book contains
companies in all categories uh from
power generation through microgrids
through process power that would be
willing to relocate or construct their
facilities in New Hampshire should the
Regulatory and um popular uh opinions
provide for that they're ready now and
we're also working with the University
Systems not only here in New Hampshire
but in our neighboring states to develop
the curricula that enables such a
skilled
Workforce this uh definition will help
us all in in getting to that
state representative parall has a
question thank you chair Vos and thank
you for coming here today um you
mentioned Next Generation nuclear lays
on a timetable for roll out within the
next decade and I'll admit that seems
ambitious to me but are you aware of any
current uh uh projects that have begun
or what is typical timeline to meet that
10-year roll out yeah I mean there are
sever
uh companies that are uh doing similar
to what we're doing um that um if if I'm
honest a little bit ahead of us there is
only one company that is on the docket
at the NRC um for licensing their new re
reactor design we believe that starcube
could have an operating reactor within
about five
years thank
you okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you very much for being
here and I hope you'll accept our
invitation to come back future
date and since I have no more pink cards
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
189 and open a public hearing on a house
bill
221 relative to assessment of cost
effectiveness of the S system benefits
charge and I'm going to ask the Bill's
Prime sponsor representative Harrington
to present this legislation to
us we have a lot of pink cards on this
one so it's going to take a while I
might have to limit um testimony to
three minutes there's another
one one more and I just received several
more
so so representative Harrington where
are you I'm right here excuse me
and when you finish your testimony I
need a pink card from you too
please good morning I'm uh Mike
Harrington represent straford uh
district 18 and this bill is a it's
about a timing issue and uh how we do
the uh cost Effectiveness review for the
um um Energy Efficiency programs and
over since I submitted this I've been
talking to some people and I realized
that there may be an issue with the
timing of this so rather than have me
pontificate up here I'd rather have
someone who actually knows the ins and
outs of it speak on it so I would defer
to the Public Utilities Commission to
address that issue
okay um you have nothing else to say
about that about the
bill I guess you're not going to accept
questions either all right so next I've
got a pin card here that wants to bring
forward Alex spidel chairman Dam goldner
chairman chatapati
and
commissioner Del arano or commissioner
chat upai and commissioner Del arano so
I don't know if you all want to come
together
or just want to let Mr spidel speak for
you or what but um yes uh Mr chairman
we'll just come up in sequence so I'll
just give a brief opening remark and
then if it would be all right I'd seed
the floor to Chairman
goldner certainly so um as by way of
opening uh the commission wanted to
thank uh the drafters of this bill just
as last year I had testified in favor of
a similar effort both here and at the
Senate um because of the importance that
the commission attaches to its uh
analytical rigor and Independence in
assessing Energy Efficiency programming
and we are very appreciative of this
effort it's a good step in the right
direction the two angles that are going
to be discussed today there's first the
tight time frame issue that may need to
be reworked as indicated by uh
representative Harrington and then the
second element that we'll put in a plug
for is for reworking or striking through
a deleting uh Roman 6 A5 which is the
following um provision of 374
DF colon 3 that would need to have some
attention in order to affect the intent
which I believe is the intent of this
bill to reactivate the commission's uh
analytical capabilities in this area so
uh without further Ado I would like to
see the floor uh and the microphone to
uh chairman goldner thank
you thank you welcome chairman
gold good morning chairman Bose uh
committee I'll just say set some brief
brief comments and being sensitive to
the time limit uh the commission as
attorney spidel U mentioned is here
today to support this bill which allows
the commission to improve trial plan
programs and is an important step in the
right
Direction I'll just touch on the 12-
month stipulation in the bill that um
that means the commission would need to
complete its work its adjudication uh in
the current year um because the next
trial plan starts on January 1st 2027
there's the 12- month stipulation so
what that means is this uh this
committee the house ultimately the
governor's signature would have to be
complete um very quickly to give us
enough time to have an adjudication so
we would just encourage uh quick passage
of the bill and uh potentially a
reduction in the 12-month window so that
uh so that we have U time to give the
parties process in in dealing with this
issue uh secondly uh as mentioned by
attorney spidel this Bell address
addresses
D4 but in D5 the legislation the
legislature only allowed uh the
commission to look at program
changes uh which means that only
3% of the current tral plan was reviewed
by the commission 97% was not reviewed
or regulated because D5 doesn't permit
the commission to uh to evaluate the
current plan it only allows the
commission to look at changes to the
plan so uh the commission would like to
encourage the committee to review that
sometime now or in the future so that uh
so that somebody's looking at the entire
plan and not just a fraction of it and
then finally in the spirit of time I'll
seed the floor to commissioner chetto
Bai of course taking any questions you
might have for me um who has some
additional observations on the benefit
to cost tests that are in this U statute
and uh and he can elaborate a little
more on some of the challenges with the
current current tests so I can take any
questions or seed the floor to to
commissioner CH any questions for the
chairman representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman thank you Mr goldner for
being here um I was here when 549 was
put out um in order to basically assist
small businesses in New Hampshire that
were participating in the New Hampshire
saves program in terms of weatherization
and other Energy Efficiency Partnerships
that they had done with the utilities so
my question is you're talking about
being able to to get at 90% 97% that is
currently not regulated in the plans
that are coming to you um after having
been developed by the utilities in
compliance with um the statutory desires
of the legislature in terms of what we
would like our Energy Efficiency
programs to do and so the question is um
can you foresee
that that
perhaps um
sanctioning off a majority of the
program is the piece that creates
stability for all of the parties that
are involved in terms of they're being
able to count on and plan for and
deliver Services into a three-year plan
it just provides stability right so I
guess my question is what is it that you
think having jurisdiction over the 97%
that remains stable uh would be of
benefit um thank you for the question I
would say that the threeyear time a in
the tral plan gives that kind of
stability of course the
legislature um allows the utilities to
come in every year for any changes that
they want so it's kind of set set up I
would say in a in a stable way but I
would say to the point of your question
that a periodic review of the programs
is uh is wise things change um
technology changes and uh and so having
a process by which there's refresh every
3 years as opposed to 97% getting stale
that could go on for even decades
without review um I would suggest at a
periodic review and every three years
seems like frequently enough uh to look
at uh the programs would would make
sense follow up so um so that would put
the Public Utilities Commission in a
position of really being a party to the
development of that plan then rather
than having as it's been since we've had
New Hampshire New Hampshire saves the
expertise has been requested from the
utilities um in order to execute the
programs and also bring evidence to the
Public Utilities Commission for
adjudication in terms of the fact that
they're meeting the standards um that
are outlined in the statute so I'm just
trying to figure out if that doesn't
change the role of the Public Utilities
Commission
[Music]
to be um participating more in the
pieces that we delegated to the
utilities it's just feels that way to me
if I could just briefly address the
question yes please um so I would say
first that the legislature wisely uh set
the budget for uh Energy Efficiency back
in 2021 in the old days prior to that
the commission set the budget but um I
believe it was completely appropriate
and sensible for the legislature to set
that budget and so that's the
environment we're now in so now
underneath that budget the question is
what's the best way to spend that money
for customers whether it's large
customers small customers uh residential
customers what's the best way to spend
the money and that gets to the very
point of this bill which is the benefit
the cost analysis that is uh sort of at
uh one big chunk of the analysis that
needs to be done in order to determine
which programs are are better than
others and the fact of it is in my
opinion that some programs and some
projects and some measures are better
than others and we want to make sure
that we're prioritizing the right
projects representative uh Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair um I'm
specifically referencing lines 10 and 11
in the bill where it says the commission
may consider modifications to the
granite state test and different or
additional tests developed through an
judicative process can you give me an
example or idea of some modifications um
of the granite state test that may be
considered or what the different or
additional tests might be thank you sure
if it would be all right commissioner
chatai has uh very brief comments on
both the granted state test the trct
test and other uh potential tests and uh
is a PhD in economics and is very well
qualified to answer that question at the
level of detail that I I think you would
want if that would be okay we can defer
that question to commissioner
chatay yes let's do that representative
Harrington has a question yeah thank you
thank you for taking my question um
point point of order excuse me hello
hang on point of order representative
Harrington um has
testified oh good point good point i'
had forgotten that so forget
representative Harrington's
question if he even asked one I'm not
sure I didn't get it written down so it
never happen his testimony was so brief
that it
just it's like passing through a little
town if you blink your eyes you could
put those words in writing so I can
bring them back to my wife because
otherwise she's not going to believe
it okay all right um representative Vice
chair Thomas has a question thank you Mr
chair um a a uh um curiosity question
you mentioned the
97% um could you define how much that is
in in real terms in in dollars it's
approximately the numbers are a little
off I didn't prepare that number for for
the hearing today but it's between $220
and $250
million yeah over a three-year time
Horizon yeah that's right okay uh let's
bring up uh commissioner chattai for his
section of this uh response
good morning commissioner and
welcome good morning and thank you for
having me here
um so let
me first make a statement and then I can
try and respond to the the questions
um and I'm going to wear the The
Economist hat here to
um to share my
thoughts when we think
about benefit to cost ratios and we are
talking
about the
society then it becomes important in my
opinion to capture all benefits as
reasonably as possible as well as all
costs that are driving the changes so
it's it's in that context when I'm
thinking about the granite state
test um as opposed to let's say the TRC
test um the granite state test is it's
based on something called a utility test
okay and it it only looks at cost that
appear in the bills and then Compares
those with the benefits that arise out
of any program um in in
reality when
the program participants even though
they spend their own money they're also
getting a big chunk from other rate
pairs that you have to understand that
resource is compete we live in a world
where resources are scarce so when
you're talking about societal impact you
need to to capture also the costs that
the program participants spend on their
own to get a better picture of what the
societal benefits are relative to the
societal costs so because the granite
state test does not do that it only it
takes out a big chunk of the cost uh
that is associated with um the
participants costs from their own
Pockets it it sort of skews the
the look at the societal test meaning
you know I'm looking at the benefits to
cost overall for the entire Society so
that is something I I I get concerned
about um there there are problems also
with the TRC test that it doesn't really
capture all of the benefits because sort
of decided okay it's harder to get a
sense of how to quantify the benefits I
think there is a need to put a lot of
stress on
analytically calculating what the
benefits are
um and that that is you know it's even
if we do it reasonably that's good but
at this point we may have not looked at
it as holistically as we should so um
those are just the comments on on the
tests that are being talked about I also
think in in the statute when you have
granite state test or even TRC it's not
defined anywhere else in the statute to
the best of my knowledge and that sort
of creates issues so
um the ability to look at the granite
state test and
this um Bill sort of does that that is a
significant Improvement but I also
commented on the overall picture so
there are there are ways to further
improve things going forward that's I'm
just sharing as an economist Viewpoint
here okay thank you so I think I under
heard you understood you to say that the
granite state test doesn't capture all
the costs and the Total
Resource cost test doesn't capture all
the
benefits so the statute currently
provides for using both together that do
they capture all the costs and benefits
not really even with the granite state
test it
could calculate the benefits better and
there are some benefits that are not
being
captured even in the granite state test
um and that is true for the TRC as
well
the sequencing matters so if you're
going to say GST is the primary test and
TRC is the secondary test it's not like
you're you're even if you're maybe
capturing all of
the benefits and the cost but you are
using them um differently for the
different test then you don't really
have a perfect sense of what what is the
best for the
society so the statute also my follow-up
question would be the statute also
provides
well actually the the bill not the
statute but the modifications to the
statute that the bill proposes would
allow the commission to consider
modifications to the granite state test
and different or additional tests is
there anything you could say about
either of those U Provisions in the in
the
bill I that's why I said that is the a
step in the right direction
but I'm also speaking
to as the term granite state test is
being used currently and TRC is being
used currently so I'm just
indicating this is this is welcome what
you have and I'm trying to justify how
this will help in getting to a better
place okay understood thank you
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
commissioner for taking my question this
is very interesting to me um it sounds
like we don't have really a good test in
your
view do you think that we actually need
to construct a whole new test and if
so who would be doing
that the way the bill is
worded it is it it will become part
of
um you know let's say a p docket where
the different parties will provide input
and that's one way to begin the process
and then I what I have indicated I mean
obviously um I'll have to be working
within the within the the the bounds and
stay in the lane as far as what is part
of the record what is not but I'm simp
just indicating that within that process
there is there are ways to improve the
test
that representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair okay I have a few um
the chairman and I uh were each members
of the easy board which was disbanded in
the last bium and it was my
understanding that um that that was
where the trienal budgets were
coordinated discussed and then brought
to the Public Utilities Commission for
adjudication so it was just was
testified to earlier that that the the
Pu was was creating those budgets and I
don't I don't think that was how it was
working before but but my question is in
your testimony you said that the all of
the costs are not captured because
you're not including the money that the
homeowner puts in when an Energy
Efficiency um project
happens and I I would argue that that
cost does not rightfully belong in the
overall cost which increases the cost
benefit ratio or lowers the cost benefit
ratio because the program was designed
to be our contribution and the um you
know our efforts at increasing Energy
Efficiency in order to lower demand
basically right it was a demand side
effort on the state of New Hamp so the
program isn't designed to um to account
for the fact that the homeowner wants to
undertake this they also are going to um
they are going to benefit from uh the
savings long term right but the if you
are looking only at the cost of the
program that we are providing through
the state and the benefits that are
happening in terms of the energy mix and
the savings then I think it is is
appropriate that it be measured the way
it is and if there were going to be a
change to that ratio then the decision
should have more uh stakeholder input
than just the public is there a question
here representative yeah no um well I
mean he's talking to us about what he
thinks is right and wrong with the way
it works right now so I had to
articulate what I thought um from the
context that I have around this process
as it's been um undertaken over the
years so my question
is can you understand what I'm saying
about the fact that I would think the
reason that the cost that the homeowner
puts in as part of the granite state
test was purposely left out and maybe
the utilities can also comment on that
because it it doesn't create the correct
cost benefit for a program it's it's not
all the things of society it's a program
and the people who are participating in
the program that you're trying to
analyze so um
respectfully first of all I wasn't part
of the process
so
secondly the whole point
is that you're trying to get to a point
where you you are targeting the societal
benefits and the societal costs properly
and the way that is being done under GST
it's completely Miss missing the point
and when it does it I could even say
it's rather convenient that you are sort
of ignoring all of the cost that the
those program participants paid but they
also got a lot of money from somewhere
else so obviously somebody is going to
be more interested in doing stuff
because they're not paying everything
from their own pocket and ultimately if
you are thinking about all New
Hampshire um citizens
then it's important that the test is
true to the fact that you're measuring
the total societal benefits and the
total costs that's of the basic tenant
of any economic efficiency analysis and
so I I mean um does that mean that if
it's if the statute says something that
we shouldn't do that no I'm not I'm just
giving you my opinions as an economist
here thank you okay thank you so let's
uh move on to uh commissioner Del arano
we have six more pink cards here of
people who would like to testify
so oh Mr de Delano has nothing to add so
are there any further questions for the
Pu no oh yes there are okay so
representative Swanson and please phrase
it as a question this is not a debate
and we don't need to hear an elaborate
background just to ask a question please
thank you Mr chair uh the question is
you talked about the test is there in
perhaps it's discussed academically does
there exist a formula
currently uh that establishes how the
test is performed available thank you Mr
chair I I don't have
the exact references here but the that
there are quite a few tests in the
literature so for for example um the
granite state test it's sort of based on
the utility test um you know concept so
um it's based on what's in the utility
bills and there are other approaches too
and um the TRC test is more like I'm
going to go with the total benefits
total costs um and in that construct
again
um different jurisdiction have chosen
different approaches different tweaks of
it but there are there are academic
there are specific measures that are um
in the
literature okay thank you all right
thank you to the Pu for being here this
morning and for giving us your
perspective on this legislation I now
would like to hear from the Department
of energy and call on Megan Stone to
give us the Department's take on this
bill the department is neutal neutral on
the
bill but likely has something to say
about it so welcome Miss
Stone thank you good morning Mr chair
and members of the committee for the
record my name is Megan Stone
legislative liaison with the Department
of energy um so as the chair said the
Department's position on this bill is
neutral um I'm just here today to give
you a little bit of background and um
some context from where we are so as
you've heard it's related to our states
rate payer funded Energy Efficiency
programs uh rate rate payer Energy
Efficiency programs are required to be
coste effective meaning they have a uh
every dollar of spending leads to at
least $1 of benefit an important
component of cost- Effectiveness
requirement is having a cost benefit
test that lets us evaluate whether
programs are in fact costeffective a
cost benefit test lets us know whether
we should or should not particular
programs and allows us to prioritize
those programs to maximize value for
rate pairs the current cost benefit test
uh which was developed by stakeholders
when the state was considering adopting
an Energy Efficiency resource standard
uh the grant state test was approved by
pu but was not yet a statutory
requirement um for a bit of background
in 2021 uh there was a decision on the
2123 Energy Efficiency plan that was uh
seen seen as unpopular among
stakeholders legisl and the then
Governor um this decision led to House
Bill 549 which was intended to stabilize
the programs and put in place guard
rails that limited the issues that the
Pu could consider one of those guard
rails was the granite state test was put
into LW and it passed both bodies
unanimously in 2024 the
2426 3year Energy Efficiency plan was
approved and in that order the puc made
a clear their interpretation of the law
was that they could not change anything
regarding the granite state test and
that interpretation means that any
changes to the cost benefit tests
remains in the hands of the
legislature House Bill uh 221 would give
the authority to change the cost benefit
test back to the PC and the bill would
lock in the grant of state test for the
remainder of the 2426 Energy Efficiency
plan then for 2729 period it would
authorize the puc to undertake
adjudicative proceedings to modify the
current cost benefit test or use
different tests um so in summary the
bill before you uh it gives the today
gives legislature the responsibility to
decide whether they want to be involved
in the details or delegate it uh back to
the Pu and that's where we are we're
neutral like I
said questions for Miss Stone
representative
capan thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr stone for coming in um I appreciate
that as a society we need to look
holistically at the cost effectiveness
of any program that the state is is uh
is sponsoring
um but just out of my own curiosity I
was wondering if you could tell me do
the benefits of the grant State the
grant state test includes a look at the
benefits do those benefits include at
this point
uh um the mitigation of climate change
that would occur as as a result of
increased Energy
Efficiency uh so I I would have to take
I would just have to double check on
that I knew the department so I just
want to get my facts straight I'll get
back
to
okay seeing no further questions we want
to thank you thank you before I call the
next person I just want to let everyone
here in the room know that house bill
224 FN scheduled at 10 10 a.m. will
actually begin as soon as we complete
the public hearing on this bill House
Bill
221 next up let's get the utility
perspective and call on Michael Lata
from eversource and Mark leminger uh as
well to get their take on this
legislation good morning
gentlemen good morning uh Michael AATA
representing eversource energy uh with
me today is Mark L menager who is our
supervisor of our Energy Efficiency
programs here in New Hampshire I
appreciate the opportunity to test tesi
for you this morning uh we are coming to
register our opposition for HB
221 uh we do appreciate the bill
sponsors intent to try to provide
additional regulatory flexibility
however we do believe that the
legislature was correct uh in 2022 when
it passed HB
549 uh which put the grant at state test
into statute at that time the
legislature heard considerable am kind
of testimony from a wide range of
different stakeholders who all spoke to
the need for a certain level of
certainty stability and understanding of
the program guard rails going
forward stability and certainty in the
development and execution of these
programs uh is really quite critical
it's critical for the utilities who
administer the programs it's critical
for the contractors who actually go out
and perform the work to weatherize homes
and improve the efficiency of a business
and most importantly it's critical to
the customers who rely on the programs
we believe that reversing HB 549 and
allowing the Pu to use a different test
that is developed through an undefined
stakeholder process raises a number of
concerns uh the timing issue has already
been discussed but we're happy to go
into uh additional detail on that but it
is important to note that the current
granite state test was developed veled
through an
extensive uh stakeholder process that I
believe took over two years before uh
approval by the Public Utilities
Commission we believe that the current
framework provides for a rigorous cost
benefit test whose inputs are regularly
updated and the result of this test is
our positive outcomes for our customers
who ultimately rely on these programs to
lower their energy costs and with that
we'd be happy to answer any questions
the committee have thank
you okay thank you let's uh start the
questioning with representative migi
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Lata for
being here Mr leminger it's good to see
you again um my question goes back to
one that I already put out there which
is the idea of including sort of the all
social benef cost and all social benefit
I my understanding is that this
individual program is not designed to to
take that kind of a global look it's
basically looking at what was spent and
the benefits that we derive from the
work that we actually did contrasting
those two things so can you speak to
that Mr linger sure the benefit cost
test working group was commenced from
2018 through 2019 the recommendations
provided in 2019 one of the aspects that
was looked at was the TRC the Total
Resource cost test which is what we used
prior to the granite state test as our
primary test it included participant
costs but excluded participant benefits
so as part of that review of the working
group we looked at should we include
both the costs and the benefits and the
result that was determined of the
working group was for symmetrical
purposes we will exclude the participant
costs because we're excluding the
participant benefits so you're able to
have if you are including one you should
be including the other the result of the
working group was we we will exclude
both because it's hard to measure or
difficult to measure sorry the
participant benefits and reach agreement
on what those values should
be followup so the follow-up would be
then do you think
um where we're at now
has reinstituted the stability that
you're looking for it sounds like from
your testimony Mr Lata you're saying
that that you think that we stabilize
the program and that we should be
looking to rework something that's
already been worked significantly right
uh so is that is that the position we
believe that the current cost test the
granite state test provides us with
certainty and stability not only for the
utilities in terms of planning the
programs but also in terms of providing
customers and contractors certainty in
terms of what types of projects and
programs are going to be provided going
forward
commissioner chattai testified that he
in his judgment the granite state test
does not capture all costs and the Total
Resource cost test does not capture all
the
benefits and I asked him at the time if
he thought that the two tests together
captured all costs and benefits and he
said he did not think so what is your
memory of the proceeding that adopted
the granite state or developed the
granite state
test
and what weaknesses may it may it have
that allow it to not capture all
costs so the Total Resource cost test
the test that was used prior to the
granite state test it includes
participant costs but excludes
participant benefits the granite state
test as part of the working group that
developed it we did not develop
participant benefits and values that we
could agree to and Associate to those
benefits therefore the participant costs
and benefits are excluded from that test
in order to preserve symmetry across the
test if you're including the cost for
participants you should be including the
benefits but since we were excluding
participant benefits the decision was
made to exclude participant
costs okay okay thank you you think
that's the right thing to
do symmetry should be included yes okay
thanks further
questions Vice chair Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
for taking my question I remember a
testimony from the Pu that basically
stated that the way it currently reads
now that the results are skewed and so
if the results are skewed how does that
affect your program in terms of who gets
the job done or in terms of how you
accurately read who um who can um
benefit from the the
program how are the results
skewed well um again that question
that's okay I think it's fair to say
that we disagree with that assessment by
the commission we do not believe that
the current test skewes the
results okay seeing no further question
questions I'd like to call next on
Michael Joy of londondary New Hampshire
who is representing
himself thank you commissioner Vos
everybody here on the committee um my
name
is Michael Joy I'm the owner and
operator of a home performance company
based in New Hampshire we employ 10
dedicated individuals and proudly serve
the State's for-profit weatherization
programs more importantly we work with
income qualified customers including
elderly residents disabled veterans
single mothers and others who are
struggling with today's rising cost uh
cost of living it feels like just
yesterday we were here celebrating the
signing of House Bill
549 which passed with an overwhelming
353 to zero vote and solidified the
granted state test a system tailored
specifically to New Hampshire's unique
needs and Today's Energy market cost s
the most critical Factor whether it's
the systems benefit charge or the price
of energy related measures these
programs are laser focused at being cost
effective in ensuring the state's
efficiency programs are responsible
stewards of public resources I'd like to
share a story that illustrates the
importance of these programs just last
Tuesday while preparing A continuing
education session for the state's energy
Auditors a colleague told me about it
interesting
encounter he had recently worked with a
client who was a staunch opponent of New
Hampshire's Energy Efficiency programs a
member of this very House of
Representatives in fact despite his opes
uh opposition the representative
admitted he was participating in the
weatherization programs because as he
put it I pay into it so I'm going to get
something out of it this is the exact
kind of customer that these programs are
design for for someone who would not
pursue weatherization without an
incentive that these programs provide
even those who oppose Energy Efficiency
initiatives recognize a fundamental
value of being comfortable in their
homes and being able to affordably heat
them that's how you know you have a good
program when even the stronger strongest
critics benefit from it and acknowledge
its necess uh necessity New Hampshire
has built a robust Energy Efficiency
program that has long protected the
interest of taxpayers rate payers and
all residents this was underscored by
the unanimous
353 zero vote in House Bill 549 a vote
that placed Energy Efficiency at the
Forefront of New Hampshire's priorities
that vote represented progress
collaboration and a commitment to the
state's Energy Efficiency plan I stand
here today in strong opposition to House
Bill
221 a poorly disguised attempt to
dismantle a program that benefits every
resident of New Hampshire all
contractors in the New Hampshire saves
program operate Within These qualified
programs as there are no contractors
dedicated dedicated exclusively to
income based services to support the
state's initiative cont rors like myself
must work across all the program types
any reduction or elimination of the New
Hampshire State's funding will have a
direct and significant impact on income
qualified individuals in New Hampshire
resulting in fewer to no Services being
provided to them under the
weatherization programs I just
appreciate your time and your thoughtful
consideration Mike Joy thank you okay
thank you we appreciate you being here
thank you next up we'd like to hear from
Matt Mayberry of the New Hampshire Home
Builders Association
uh representative Wendy Thomas has a
quick question thank you Mr chairman and
um thank you Mr Joy for being here thank
you we've had some discussion about the
granite state test and you seem to have
uh a fairly good understanding of the
granite state test as someone who
actively works in the field have you
seen any deficiencies from the test that
apply directly to your
customers for us
no thank you it was a quick question
okay thank you representa I mean um
we'll next call on Matt Mayberry of the
New Hampshire homebuilders
Association good morning Mr chairman
committee members thanks for serving
thanks for being here my name is Matt
mayber and the CEO of the New Hampshire
homebuilders Association we represent
the 27,000 people who earn living
through the Residential Building Trades
within this Dynamic organization we have
quite literally thousands of individuals
and businesses who earn a living through
the weatherization industry thousands of
grand Staters are able to stay in their
homes through the weatherization
programs that receive their funding from
Energy Efficiency programs run through
New Hampshire
saves the New Hampshire homebuilders
Association urges this committee to
either vote down or label this bill as
itl we are opposed to the the passage of
HB
221 the very same pu that this
legislature had to very publicly correct
when they made an attempt to claw back
$76 million from the poorest of our
neighbors is being set up to dictate
programs once again from their unelected
Purge do the members of this committee
remember that the Pu did an executive
order issued on the last hour of the
last day of the former chair's reign
it was going to devastate hundreds of
small businesses but you fought
back this legislature said very loudly
and unanimously that weatherization and
every effort to reduce heating cost
matters in the granite state the New
Hampshire legislature has the final word
however the legislation as drafted sets
up an adjudicative process and has the
authority to approve Pro changes prior
to the next
cycle who was involved in the
adjudicative process what happened to
outlining which stakeholders shall be
involved in not only the process but in
the rulemaking authority what happened
to the to approval through the
legislature any public Hearing in the
vague adjudicative process it's not
outlined in there once again this
legislature allowed an unelected body to
set up a policy for the state New
Hampshire affecting tens of thousands of
our
neighbors don't seed your Authority
don't seed what we elected you to do the
New Hampshire home builder Association
is focused on providing attainable
housing for New Hampshire one thing that
business in general cannot stand nor
Thrive within is
uncertainty how can we provide
affordable and Workforce housing when we
don't know what utility programs will be
available
how can we provide career opportunities
when manufacturers looking to come into
the state can't count on programs to
reduce the electric Bills versus the
will and whim of an unelected
body please help us get through this
housing challenge with stability and
predictability this is the wrong time to
introduce variables into our housing
market please vote itl on HB 221 thank
you for your time today and have a nice
day questions for Mr
Mayberry representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Mayberry for coming in um just a
quick background I am somebody who's who
took advantage of the New Hampshire
saves last year and um reinsulated some
of my house and I can tell you that the
the Comfort level this winter is is is
without measure so I I just wondered
would you agree with me that uh in terms
of costs and benefits I find it hard to
be able to quantify the benefit of
somebody living in a you know a warm and
secure house and and how would you
quantify that in your opinion you don't
have to answer that members have been
warned that would you agree with me
questions are not appropriate for this
committee so I want to thank you for
being here Mr Mayberry yes Mr chairman
okay we'll call next on Michael
turkot who is here to represent turn
cycle Solutions
good morning Mr
chairman your members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to provide
my testimony today my name is Michael
turkot and I'm here in strong opposition
of HB 221 this bill inacted would pose a
significant harm to the Energy
Efficiency and energy reduction
initiatives that are instrumental in
driving New Hampshire's process across
the state these programs not only reduce
energy consumption and cost for
residents businesses
but they also play a critical role in
Foster economic growth and environmental
stability in this
community one of my primary concerns is
the devastation the impact of this
legislation would have on my
employment the Energy Efficiency sector
is thriving in New Hampshire providing
thousands of well-paying job across
diverse Fields the instability of HB 221
would provide me as a business owner
projecting
instability leaving hardworking families
without income and significantly
weakening our local
economy in addition to this direct
impact on my employment and our business
it's the Energy Efficiency initiatives
would create a financial step
back to our local constituents these
programs offer uh enable companies to
lower operational costs in incur
increase competitive nature expand their
operations and removing cultural the uh
excuse me
curtailing um these efforts would
disrupt the positive impact and H hinder
the growth cycle within our
state my name is Michael turkot and I'm
strongly in opposition of HB 221 happy
to take any questions chairman thank you
Mr turkot you asserted in the at the
beginning of your testimony that this
legislation would
desate or destroy the Energy Efficiency
programs in our state
how does the specifically does the
language of this bill do that so since
uh I can speak to um to our business
since HB 549 was um cleaned or or passed
I should say sir and so that allowed us
um when there was inst instability in
the market to feel very confident to
reinvest into our specific business um I
know counterparts of mine uh who will
speak today and already have uh the home
Performance Contractors we feel as
though that now we can invest into our
companies with stability with this
three-year plan what this bill does is
it allows in my interpretation the Pu or
someone else to make radical changes I I
say on a whim in my personal opinion
where right now I have a stable
structure to to actually grow and Foster
our business I'll take that a step
further sir we we grew our business
through the last two years from 15
employees to 30 knowing that the
consideration of that bill provided us a
guarantee that we could grow in this New
Hampshire economy uh we we as uh
employees now or we have employees now
which is 30 employees I'm sorry I'm a
little flustered 30 employees total um
and we we support a lot of families that
way as well just do that
work okay seeing no further questions
we'll move next
to and I hope I'm going to get this
right that the handwriting is little
ambiguous
Chase either pager or
penoyer who's here from conquered to
represent
himself good morning honorable chairman
Bose and members of the committee my
name is Chase penoyer and I'm here to
represent myself uh and I oppose HB 221
I'm a business owner I I uh just
recently purchased a company called
resilient Billings group based here in
conquer and we have 16 employees were
dedicated to finding costeffective
Energy Efficiency improvements
throughout the state I oppose this bill
because it essentially eliminates the
guard rails that have been uh created uh
with HB 549 and I'll never forget that
Friday evening when the uh leaving uh
chair person of the Pu put an order that
completely scrapped the Energy
Efficiency programs I haven't been in
this room since HB 549 hearings and it
was an incredibly tumultuous time uh in
my career but also in in the
business I oppose this legislation HB
221 for really three main reasons the
first is that I see every day customers
benefiting from New Hampshire saves I
see customer custers that are are uh
engaged and and getting projects that
are uh resulting in in uh economic
returns for years to come this is this
is daily if our customers didn't like
the programs or didn't have good
experiences we wouldn't be in business
it's just as simple as that the other
reason that I oppose hb22 is because I
um believe in in jobs I'm I have 16
employees I'm one of the contractors
here that I think just in this room we
represent over a 100 full-time employees
it's significant and in Energy
Efficiency as an industry there are
thousands it's not just me Consultants
or insulators or
HVAC um technicians it's electricians
it's Builders it's so many people in the
state and I think it's so very important
to provide stability in in this Arena
the the third reason why I oppose this
legislation is because of and we've all
sort of touched on it we as as business
owners can't operate in an unstable
environment without stability in the
marketplace I don't know what I'm going
to do and if cost Effectiveness is
questioned in New Hampshire saves that
means that most of our projects probably
won't pass a new cost Effectiveness
standard that has unknown variables I'm
I'm not an economist but every single
one of our projects goes through a
rigorous calculation every single one of
our projects that receives utility
funding is vetted so it's not like we're
out here just getting
uh uh or or elaborate or uh overly
expensive projects through the gate I
mean this is this is real work that's
that's vetted um and with that uh I can
take questions
thank
you seeing no questions I want to thank
you for your testimony I have one more
pink card for this public hearing and it
is from Mr cof of the conservation law
foundation and I noticed you've also
filed a card to testify on the next bill
I was wondering if you would wave off
this bill and uh do multiple testimony
for your next bill for the next
bill
yes because I'm sure you're going to say
basically the same thing for both bills
so all right
so
yes we have been limited to addressing
the bill at hand when we're discussing
uh the bills and if we are if he waves
off we will not be able to ask him about
this particular bill that's my
understanding of what we're doing right
now that is
correct thank you I I I I'm opposed
to having him wave off it's his choice
of course but I mean if we can't ask him
about this right let's put it to a vote
all those in favor of it uh letting Mr
Koff testify once on both bills raise
your hand please
okay all those opposed raise your
hands okay Mr coff you can come up now
thank you make it quick we're way behind
on introducing the next
Bill thank you very much and I promise
to make it very very quick um again Nick
R off with the conservation law
Foundation um I wasn't planning to
testify on this bill today but there was
something that the commissioner said uh
the PC commissioner said particularly
commissioner chattai said that I really
wanted to respond to here today which is
really important um so in in the bill in
the sorry the order order n uh
27074 in the net metering docket um you
know their conservation law foundation
made an argument that basically when
looking at the benefits of net metering
they should also be looking at the
environmental public health
benefits um the the
PC rejected that argument but I I want
to focus your attention on the reasoning
there they basically said unless the
commission is a valuating the financial
costs and benefits to raid payers it is
not clear how the commission would
evaluate cost shifting between customer
categories because neither category
benefits from the external benefits as a
member of that rate they said the
commission does not know how it Factor
benefits unrelated to reductions in
rates into the cost shifting
analysis and then they said notably
while balancing the financial costs and
benefits of a program is within the
commissional traditional ratemaking
Authority looking at benefits and costs
outside of that is not in their
traditional ratemaking Authority so what
what chat what commissioner chatai said
was that you know basically they want to
look at costs outside of that
traditional rate making Authority which
is contrary to what was said here I
think if they're going to be looking at
participant costs not traditional rate
making you know cost not traditional
cost to rate payers they should also be
looking at societal benefits and it's
very concerning that they're talking
about looking at societal costs but not
societal benefits thank you for
um any questions for Mr
Cot representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr cof for coming in so given what you
just said uh would it be beneficial to
uh Us in order to vote on this bill to
see exactly what factors the Pu would be
looking at in terms of costs and
benefits if they're going to look at
traditional rate making then that's not
a holistic look if they're going to do a
holistic look then maybe we ought to
know
what that entails and what frame they're
going to use I mean I would agree I mean
I I think it you know it's important to
know what they're thinking in terms of
societal costs and benefits because you
know it does appear to be very one-sided
and and I would also note that you know
as um as ever sources Witnesses said
when they developed the grant state test
it was basically a compromise you
weren't going to look at societal costs
weren't going to look at societal
benefits and here at least a proposal
I've heard today is to only look at one
one side of the equation
okay seeing no further questions I want
to thank you and I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 221 and
we're going to move directly into a
public hearing for House Bill 224
FN relative to rebates to rate payers
from the renewable energy fund and I'll
call on the prime sponsor of this
legislation representative Janine nter
to introduce this bill to
us good morning repres representative n
good morning Mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record I'm Janine
n Hillsboro 12 Town of marac and at
10:24 I don't know if anybody else felt
it but we had a little
earthquake just putting it out there is
4.1 in
Nashville inflation has made it harder
for the citizens of New Hampshire to get
by and this is particularly true among
seniors people are concerned about
increases in groceries energy costs and
these are the areas where constituents
really can't fully cut back because they
are
Essentials unfortunately for many of
these expenses like groceries and
gasoline the legislature doesn't have
any leverage in impacting these prices
they are set by national or Global
markets that are beyond our
control so I looked for where we can
make an impact and help citizens
particularly our seniors who are often
on fixed incomes
this bill addresses one area where we
can help keep a little more money in the
pockets of our residents their
electricity bill lowering energy costs
is an issue I ran on by rebating the
renewable energy fund back to rate
payers we would save them according to
the fiscal note between $2.5 and $7.3
million per year while that's not going
to save each rate payer thousands of
dollars each year it's a start and an
important step to provide relief from
some of the highest electricity costs in
the
country this isn't a new concept as this
committee knows well New Hampshire has
been rebating funds from our Reggie
program for 13 years and has saved rate
payers hundreds of millions of dollars
over that time frame this bill seeks to
do the same for the renewable energy
fund and provide important rate payer
relief since I've filed this bill a
number of organizations have expressed
their support for this
legislation I know that several of them
are here today and I look forward to
hearing their testimony from the
constituencies that they
represent and I reserve my right to
respectfully ask you to direct your
questions to them accordingly I
encourage the committee to find this
bill ought to pass and give our rate
payers the relief they need thank
you thank you representative n for
introducing this
bill I have about 10 pink cards here I'm
sorting through them even as I speak to
try to find out just
exactly who I think we need to hear from
next and I think we need to hear next
from Josh Elliot at the New Hampshire
Department of
energy good morning Mr Elliott and
welcome good morning Mr chairman members
of the committee for the record Josh
Elliott I am serve as the Director of
the division of policy and programs uh
with the New Hampshire Department of
energy uh so the department is uh
neutral on this bill although some of
the uh the details were unclear to us is
the exact intent uh of the of the
language of the bill um given the
language that is struck out on lines 12
through 16 um and then the addition of
the language um specifically on lines 16
and 17 uh that reads that are in excess
of administrative costs and incentive
payments so uh if listening to the
um the prime sponsor she introduced the
bill it sounds like the intent would be
to rebate any money that comes in from
the R into the uh the renewable energy
fund from alternative compliance
payments um although this language does
not do that um it does say in excess of
administrative costs and incentive
payments although the language that is
struck out above strikes out the
language about incentive uh any
incentive payments being made so it's
not clear to us what exactly um is the
intent if the intent is to uh create
some sort of uh relief valve if you will
um if there were sort of an anomalous
year where I'm making up numbers given
that this number has not happened say
$30 million were made in alternative
compliance payments because of a variety
of circumstances beyond the control of
this legislature um given that renewable
energy certificates uh trade regionally
um you know we could see you know
working on language to try to figure out
okay after you know proper notice and
hearing doing something like that so
there's appropriate um um uh input in
terms of what that mechanism looks like
and what is considered excess um because
that is not clear in the legislation uh
as proposed either but we're happy to
work with the prime sponsor any other
members of the committee to to further
refine
that okay questions for Mr Elliott Wendy
Thomas has one thank you Mr chair um I
actually have two economic questions I
can do one as a followup um on line
it strikes out um that these funds shall
be subject to audit
so if one reads this bill as is there is
absolutely no audit oversight on $7.3
million is that something that
department of energy is okay
with uh thank you for the question
representative uh yes as you as you
pointed out correctly right that's Str
that uh sentence is struck out um if
there are uh if the if the intention is
to remove any incentive payments
whatsoever um I guess all the audit
would do would be to say whether or not
the money is coming in the same number
that's flowing into the department is
the same number flowing out of the
department
um it could be read a couple of
different ways in terms of whether or
not it doesn't prohibit us from doing it
but it certainly removes the specific
legislative directive to do it followup
followup as a member of the Department
of energy can you make a comment on the
economic impact of death estimating the
Energy Efficiency industry in New
Hampshire if this bill passes um given
that I am not fully in aware of the full
intent of the legislation um I would
defer that defer answering that question
respectfully thank
you additional questions for the
Department representative McGee has one
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question Josh good to see you
um so
uh I guess I just have a question about
the renewable energy fund usage in other
words I'd like to get to what you're
doing with that money if it's going to
evaporate because as you're aware um the
prime sponsor when she testified
mentioned that we're already rebating
quite a bit of money from the regional
greenhouse gas initiative money which
was for Investments this program is also
a much smaller program for investment um
so what will be the impact of not having
any renewable energy fundings for the
State uh thank you for the question so I
can speak to what the programs that are
currently operated out of this fund um
so there are uh three rebate programs
commercial industrial solar commercial
industrial uh wood pellet as well as a
residential wood pellet program uh there
are two um Grant programs that are
currently operating a low moderate
income solar uh grant program as well as
a non-competitive excuse me a
competitive uh commercial industri
program um at the direction of the
legislature in the last sessions as part
of Senate Bill 303 uh the department is
working on a municipal solar program um
at the legislature's direction um so
that that program has not been fully set
up yet and it an operational but that
would assumingly assume would uh if this
bill were to pass with cl would be
disrupted yes it would we would just
stop work on that um I would add um this
also removes uh the funding for the
office of offshore wind industry and
energy innovation so including all the
nuclear duties that were passed um a
number uh last session um the the office
itself would still exist we would just
not have a funding stream for
it
followup so many things going on in my
brain right now so the other question
that I have is I believe that we also
have a bill to consider removing the RPS
and my question is if the funding comes
from the alternative compliance
payments if that bill passes would there
be no funding in this fund all coming in
it because I'm trying to get it all
straight in my head it would depend on
how that bill is
structured uh I have a quick question
for you rather than
rebating the proceeds that are derived
from alternative compliance
payments would it be economically
advantageous to eliminate alternative
compliance payments altogether and would
that stimulate Renewable Energy Credit
sales and ultimately lower cost for rate
payers
um if you were to eliminate acps right
there would be no penalty for financial
or otherwise for not purchasing
renewable energy certificates by the
utilities and they would just in theory
they would buy whatever they could on
the open market but there would be no
there would be no Financial incentive
for the utilities to not purchase
them I again it would depend on the
details I I would have to think about it
a little bit more and see what the a
proposal would actually look like okay
thank
you representative Harrington has a
question yeah um getting to the
renewable energy fund and the alternate
complaint liance payments I I believe
the goal of the legislation was to have
maximizing the amount of renewable
energy being produced in New Hampshire
so ultimately we would want the
alternate compliance payments to go to
zero that would mean that uh we don't
have we have all the uh renewable energy
that the law uh is trying to accomplish
given that um what percentage of this
goes to alternate compliance payments as
compared to you know uh goes to I guess
you say how much we spending on
Alternate compliance payments because
that means we're not developing
renewable energy uh to the extent we
could or the utilities say it's cheaper
to buy alternate make alternative
clients payments rather than to provide
renewable energy recks so how much is
going to this um thank you for the
question so the amount going to
Alternative compliance payments varies
over the year depending on variety of of
factors that are outside of uh the
Department's control or even this
legislature's control um in terms of um
how those renewable energy certificates
are bought and sold on an open market um
last year go ahead uh last year um I'm
trying to remember off the top of my
head it was in our renewable energy fund
uh annual report which I'm happy to
provide to the committee uh again the um
I want to say was somewhere around5 or
$6 million um as compos as opposed to
the the cost of the renewable energy
certificates um that were acquired by
the utilities um you know we're
probably trying to remember off the time
top of my head probably about six times
that
number yeah could you provide I know you
can't do it up the top of your head
could you provide us the the value of
the renewable energy recck credits and
the alternate compliance payments for
the last five years and you you submit
it to us please thank yes I can do
that representative rolds has a
question sorry thank than you Mr
chairman um I I think that the
concepts the concepts and the policy
instruments that we're discussing here
are getting a little bit
confused um Mr Elliot isn't it true that
obviously as the uh renewable en the
requirement that the utilities
acquire certain percentage of renewable
energy certificates is really a stand in
for the utilities acquiring a certain
fraction of their electricity
Supply directly from renewable
sources yes so those renewable energies
okay certificates yes are the are the
renewable attributes of of electricity
that's produced yes and isn't it true
that the alternate compliance payments
is a policy instrument that was designed
as a cap a price cap tap on that so that
the utilities would not be required to
pay you know some ungodly price for
renewable energy instead of paying say
$100 a megawatt hour they might they can
instead make an alternative compliance
payment to the fund and then that fund
is
used to support other people developing
renewable energy yes that is correct
okay thank you
okay any more questions representative
parshall
chair um thank you for being here today
A recent Stanford study places another
30 40 years uh before natural gas and
toing reserves are
exhausted
um putting the Val um with surrounding
states investing heavily in
Renewables if New Hampshire steps away
from this Market will they not put us as
a dis over the next four decades and our
ability to compete in the energy
Market uh given that that I have not
read that study I'm not aware of that
study I'd be happy to take a look at it
if you send it to me um I'd love to uh
it's a uh this sort of fundamentally
comes down as a policy decision for the
legislature depending on what how they
want to do this um in terms of peak Peak
natural gas or Peak whatever fuel
happens to be um I'm I am not an expert
in in that area so I unfortunately I
can't offer an opinion on that now in
terms of what are you asking what in
terms of the the impact would be on the
the renewable energy Market within the
state in terms of
the I allow to clarify yes clarify
please yes I'm uh I'm looking at Vermont
that has 100% renewable at this point uh
Maine has uh 63% I believe and um
they're getting their energy basically
for free compared to what being 45% of
our energy being DED from natural gas
and that's that's going to have extreme
volatility for down down the
future um with volatile prices like that
well will that be a discouraging uh
businesses say from coming to our state
because our in prices will continue to
be high particularly in terms of what
other states surrounding us are doing so
the the question has wandered into
territory that is outside the scope of
this bill so you respectfully don't have
to answer answer that okay thank you I
want to be respectful the committee's
time thank you representative Kaplan do
you have a question that's about the
bill yeah I mean this this uh yeah thank
you Mr chair and and thank you Mr
Elliott uh this this bill would
essentially cancel out the the uh the
compli the U the renewable energy fund
which is based on compliance payments uh
so what effect would that have on the on
our um ability to integrate additional
renewable energy sources or even clean
energy sources in our
state it would uh the impact would be
those those programs that I I outlined
uh in response to I apologize I can't
remember if it was representative oh
representative McGee's question um would
uh with sunset uh in terms of the gross
impact on terms of of New Hampshire
itself um I can't say particularly in
terms of you know how many projects
would not get down how many you know
what in terms of the larger impact of
the grid I could not I could not answer
that
question all right seeing no more
questions I want to thank uh Mr Elliott
for giving us the Department's
perspective we're running out of time
and we have a lot of people who want to
speak so we're going to have to start uh
implementing a limit time limit on
testimony so next I want to call on John
Reynolds represent of Amherst New
Hampshire representing
nfib NH and I am sure he will tell us
what nfib NH is Mr Reynolds welcome you
have three minutes please I'll be uh try
to be much briefer uh thank you Mr chair
and members of the committee my name is
John Reynolds with the national
Federation of Independent Business of
New Hampshire uh that's why we
abbreviate it uh nfib New Hampshire
represents over 1,700 small businesses
across the state in every size every
industry um and our mission is to
promote protect the right of our members
to own operate and grow their business
um every four years nfib surveys our
members every four years since 1982
we've surveyed our members on their
biggest uh problems and priorities we
put 75 issues in front of them and ask
them to rank them so you can imagine
it's very hard to get a response uh when
you put 75 issues in front of people but
uh there's been an emergence recently as
I'm sure you've heard from lots of your
constituents uh in the concern of the
cost of energy so both uh Transportation
fuels and heating fuels and the cost of
electric rates have entered the top 10
in the most recent Edition which was
published last year and earlier this
year earlier this month we surveyed New
Hampshire small businesses um on whether
they believed policy makers should focus
on reliability and affordability
accelerate the deployment of Renewables
or something else and 87% of small
business owners said that the top policy
priority should be affordability and
reliability um I would also note that in
the at the federal level the 2022
inflation reduction act uh included in
the climate and clean energy provisions
of that bill uh nearly a trillion or
over a trillion dollars worth of value
for alternative energy renewable energy
um and Energy Efficiency projects
according to a Penn Warton study um
that's compared to the original $380
billion 10year
estimate and while we recognize as
representative ner said uh while we
recognize that hb24 doesn't solve the
entire affordability problem uh it will
give small business owners a little
break on their electric bills and that's
why we support the bill so again thank
you to the committee for your time and I
appreciate uh representative n
sponsoring the
bill okay thank you representative
Harrington has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking U my
question would you say that even though
it's a small step it's a step in the
right direction at least it shows
businesses that would try and do the
best we can even that we don't have
control over a lot of electrical
expenses is any step in the right
direction sending a message to
businesses that New Hampshire's trying
to do what it can I think uh we
wholeheartedly agree with that and in my
uh e effort to trim down the time of my
testimony I think I omitted the fact
that this is a small step in the right
direction thank you representative
Corman has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh so the fiscal note says that
over the last 10 years AP ACP Revenue
has varied between 2.5 and 7.3
million so in terms of how that would
affect a an independent Independent
Business given its share of the rebate
what actual effect would that have on a
typical Independent Business are we
talking about um the ability of the
business to stay afloat or hire more
people or just make more profit for the
owners what is the actual impact to a
business uh for our members thank you
for the question Mr chair um and
representative Corman uh you know for
our members I think any money that uh
comes back to them through relief from
the state right is money that they're
most likely going to invest back in
their business or into their employees
um and so whether it's $100 or $200 or
$500 or $1,000 um you know that's
probably where the savings is going and
I I think of when I think of res uh
small businesses independent businesses
that would benefit the most from this I
think of you know places like
restaurants uh small independent grocery
stores right that have uh typically very
high energy costs
or where where energy is one of their
you know largest expenses representative
Wendy Thomas thank you uh Mr chair um
thank you for being here can you please
give me um the percentage of your small
business clients that have taken
advantage of the New Hampshire saves
programs and its offerings uh thank you
for the question representative Thomas
Mr that doesn't really apply to this
bill you don't you don't have to answer
it if you don't want I I don't have the
percentage of that I we haven't asked
our members that question so I don't
have an answer to that question
representative representative
rals thank you Mr chairman well I was
going to ask a similar question but
directly related to the bill because do
you know how many um in small businesses
in New Hampshire have taken advantage of
the renewable energy fund to do projects
I mean when I drive around the state I
see a lot of small
roofs um installations where there's
solar energy so your members are are
participating do you have a sense of the
numbers I uh don't have a sense Mr chair
uh and representative rolds uh I don't
have a sense of how many members
participate in those programs um but
again I would refer back to our survey
from earlier this month that said 87%
believe that the top priority should be
affordability and
reliability okay we'd like to move on
here because we have a lot of people we
want to hear from up next we'll hear
from Mark froing of fr in
energy good morning Mr Fring nice to see
you again I was just passing by one of
your facilities in Keen yesterday oh oh
okay I was there yesterday working on a
Sunday um thank you so much Mr Bose
representative
W um I run a small Renewable Energy
company and we install uh wood pallet
boilers and wood chip boilers throughout
the several different states and we are
um obviously uh you know in all
transparency we're a big beneficiary of
um the fund the renewable energy fund
that um gives out grants uh to not to us
necessarily but to our clients and so
then we get work from that fund and that
has helped us grow to a 30 uh sorry to a
20 person Company by now and um we also
uh because we have um manufactured or
started to manufacture Uh Wood fuel fuel
over the years we also um sell the wood
fuel throughout the states and our
biggest client is actually um
municipalities and and counties and
jails and hospitals and nursing homes
and things like that and they all
benefit of this wreck money that they
receive and we have um we we sell about
or we broker about um 20% of the Recs
that are actually generated by this fund
a little bit under half a million dollar
and so that has helped all of our
clients and actually our clients are the
biggest beneficiaries of these things
and so looking at that it doesn't seem
very logical what this bill is doing
because you are giving the rate payers
the money or you're intending to give
the rate payers the money back but in
fact uh the people that are really
benefiting is the state and the
communities and the
municipalities and so in the future they
when you take these funding
opportunities away they would cost more
and who is the state but ourselves and
so then we would have to pay more taxes
into that so you're sort of taking it
out of one pocket and then putting it
into another pocket and that to me seems
not the intent of this um fund this fund
is really to reduce greenhouse gases and
that's what we're trying to do and um I
strongly oppose this bill but thank you
so much for your time and
consideration thank you any questions
any questions for Mr froling
representative
rold thank you Mr chairman um hearkening
back to the
prior uh
Witnesses uh Mantra you know that small
businesses everyone is seeking you know
affordable and reliable energy yeah uh
and recognizing that the grants from the
renewable energy fund provide you know
uh a fraction of the of the capital cost
of the installation of your equipment
are the are your are your C are your
clients installing wood pellet and wood
chip boilers because they believe
that having that equipment as their main
source of heating for the next 30 Years
is going to give them affordable and
reliable
energy yes yes that's exactly who our
customers are so I will give you a
really really discreet um example um our
local chesher County nurse ing home um
is a project where they were spending
$300,000 a year on fuel oil in the past
to heat their facilities and then during
a very large major remodel of the entire
nursing home um they reduced their
annual hiting bills down to
$80,000 and this fund was um I'm not I
think it was 300,000 or maybe
$325,000 um grant money that was part of
generated from this fund and then
additionally to that they're also
getting the Rex and because of that the
nursing home and the entire chesher
County complexes are the beneficiaries
of that and that actually helps our
community so it's not just sort of um
you know it's a it's a great um it's a
great fund for us for sure and I am a
beneficiary of that because that's how I
make my living but also the the people
in the state are the beneficiaries
because they are getting the savings
from from the fuel that we're providing
at half the cost of oil so it's a much
greater impact than the $2 you're
getting back as as a rate paay okay
thank you very much let's move on next
I'll call up Mr Greg Moore from
Americans for
Prosperity and uh you asked for four
minutes I'm afraid I'm GNA have to give
you just three thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the
opportunity to speak here today for the
record my name is Greg Moore I am a
regional director with Americans for
Prosperity and I'm here today to testify
in support of houseu 224 first of all uh
let me address some of the technical
components um I agree with the chairman
I think that a better solution to to
resolving this might just to be to bring
the ACP down to zero uh that takes takes
out takes out the challenge of giving
the Pu having to develop a mechanism in
order to rebate this money back to the
right players it seems like a more a
simpler solution which legislatively I
always like simpler Solutions um I'd
also like to point out the fiscal note
raised a good point about the the office
of offshore wind industry development
energy
Innovation um given the fact that that
the new Administration signed an
executive order uh basically putting an
end to development of wind energy uh it
this this uh Bill actually flagged for
the for the committee something that
another action you might want to take
considering that uh at least probably
for the next four years that's not going
to be a real viable option and we're
spending at a cost of
125,000 uh while I agree with the prime
sponsor we come at this bill a little
bit differently our focus is on overall
State competitiveness if you hear me
speaking in front of legislative
committees you'll usually hear me talk
about State competitiveness and we want
to do everything we can to make New
Hampshire the obvious choice for people
to come to whether it's individuals
businesses Etc so anything we can do to
take small steps in that direction we
think is a is a good and viable one we
encourage the committee to consider this
legislation and U I'll I'll be short
I'll give you two minutes happy to take
any
questions thank you we had someone who
testified earlier state that a survey of
the members of his organization the
small business New Hampshire Independent
Business Association 87% of the members
said that their top energy priority was
affordability and reliability do you
have any similar statistics for members
of your organization we have not
surveyed our members on on this topic so
I I can't say that I have anything
conrete I will tell you that uh I spend
time talking to uh individuals as well
as business owners every day and uh
energy is a huge huge issue particularly
I was talking with somebody who has
businesses in Massachusetts New
Hampshire and Maine and he talks about
the fact that uh as they do what he
calls a spreadsheet Olympics which is
laying out all hoc caust associated with
each state to try to understand where he
wants to sort of locate his business he
said that in his in his interpretation
New Hampshire is making the right
decisions and it's and it seems like the
Gap is widening in as he describes at
the spreadsheet Olympics making New
Hampshire more and more attractive every
day good that's a good feedback thank
you any further questions uh
representative Swanson has
one maybe I lost track of the thread
there but uh uh if New Hampshire is
getting more attractive any every day
how would getting you know how would
this bill make it even more attractive
when it seems like the consequences of
investing in Renewables is making New
Hampshire more
attractive uh representative I would I
would point out that uh New England as a
whole has some of the highest energy
costs electricity costs in the country
the the US Department of energy uh eia
uh Energy Information agency typically
puts New Hampshire between the fourth
and sixth most expensive and and when
you take out Alaska and Hawaii who have
their own unique electricity challenges
we typically fall between between the
second and and the fifth highest
electricity cost in any given time it's
a huge problem I look for example at Sig
sour uh when they decided to make an
Ammunition plant uh they as you know
they they manufactur lot of firearms out
in the Sea Coast but when they were
looking to do a manufacturing an
Ammunition plant they cited the high
cost of electricity now they want to be
here they love New Hampshire they want
to be here but they cited the high cost
of electricity as the reason why they
cited their Ammunition plant in
Arkansas following question follow up as
a
homeowner who's invested in my solar
system I have found that since Ming back
to New Hampshire in the first year and a
half a question please okay uh well I
had power failures but after I installed
my own system I no longer have power
outage I don't have those you know I
have reliability I have where's your
question please and my question is as
follows what is the statistic as far as
what is the impact of the cost of the
current program relative to driving up
rates because that does seem like the
assertion well according to the fiscal
note um it says that in the last few
years that cost has been Associated
between 2.5 and $7.3 million that has
been added on to to rate payers uh I
will say this as someone who just
recently uh replaced a f a gas furnace
uh by the way always a good idea if
you're going to replace a gas furnace do
it in the summertime not in the winter
but I replaced it with an ultra high
efficiency one and I did it because it
was going to save me money
I didn't need a government program to do
that I did it because it was going to
save me money in the long run thank you
Mr
chair representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for coming in Mr Moore uh and based
on on your uh on your comment just just
the the latest comment about needing uh
you know government help to to take
those kind of steps to save electricity
and or energy and your own home um as as
a member of a community whose High
School took advantage of the wood p
boiler program to lower its operating
cost and therefore save the entire
community on its property taxes which is
a huge issue for our state um would you
would your
membership acknowledge the value in
terms of our competitiveness relative to
other states of having viable
communities and having an educated
Workforce I'm not sure I understand the
through line but uh I will say that I
will say that that uh if projects makes
sense very frequently people will engage
in those projects because they make
Financial sense our town of our town of
B Bedford has bonded out several Energy
Efficiency projects I'm not aware of
them getting funding uh from the state
maybe they have maybe they haven't but
we did it because it was going to save
money for for the town and the
taxpayers representative Wendy Thomas
has a question thank you Mr chair um you
mentioned specifically the executive
order on Banning offshore wind in New
Hampshire and you said that there's not
going to be anything for the next four
years so we shouldn't look at it are you
aware of the many legal challenges that
are currently being filed against that
EO I am that question doesn't relate to
the bill so you don't have to answer
that if you
don't representative parshall thank you
chair and thank you for being here today
um this
bill will remove I believe correct me if
I'm wrong we'll remove some of our fuel
diversity from our mix and I tend to see
fuel diversity as stabilization of our
electric rates would you agree with well
I don't want to make me
um could you see a situation where not
having fuel diversity can make us less
competitive among our neighbor States oh
I think this this committee has has done
great move forward greatly in the notion
of fuel diversity I think the work that
that this committee has done in the area
of nuclear has been exceptional and is
frankly a leader uh not just not just
regionally but nationally so I I think
that you guys are doing a great job and
trying to find good fuel
diversity thank you okay saying no
further questions I want to thank Mr Mo
for being here and pleas next call
on Miss Heidi koll representing the
granite state Hy Hydro Power Association
and Miss CR I know you asked for five to
six minutes I'm afraid I'm going to have
to limit you to three
in the interest of time but welcome and
it's nice to see you again good morning
uh Mr chairman and members of the
committee um I will try to be as brief
as possible uh my name is Heidi croll I
work at um J gmis strategic Solutions
and I'm here on uh today on behalf of
the Granite State Hydro Power
Association um we are opposed to uh this
bill um and as I from what I understand
um from the uh Prime sponsor's um
description of her intent with it um the
renewable energy um fund is a
continually appropriated dedicated
non-aps fund funded by alternative
compliance payments and as a general
principle dedicated funds should not be
used for purposes for which they were
not established or intended um when the
legislature design the RPS the renewable
energy fund was seen as a critical
feature not only in helping to increase
the supply of renewable energy in New
Hampshire but also in lowering the RPS
compliance cost um the renewable energy
fund is um intended to help support and
promote all types of uh new
hampshire-based renewable energy
projects uh in terms of size Renewable
Fuel customer class and this helps
increase the supply of renewable energy
certificates thereby bringing the cost
of RPS compliance down because load
serving entities don't have to pay the
ACP which is the cealing price and which
uh therefore is the highest price um doe
as you heard from uh Mr Elliott uh uses
the funds from the renewable energy fund
to administer several rebate programs a
low-income grant program and a
competitive grant program for
non-residential renewable energy
projects that are not eligible for any
of the other programs um the renewable
energy fund leverages significant
private investment in new and existing
renewable energy resources according to
the Doe's November 2024 report the
programs funded by the renewable energy
fund since in since Inception have
leveraged private investment by ratio of
over 6 to1 which means for every $1 of
ref they're getting $6 in private
investment um a number of hydro
facilities throughout New Hampshire have
competed for and been awarded grants
under the um commercial and Industrial
competitive grant program which is again
the only one the only program that they
are eligible for um and these grants
have provided U small but meaningful
contribution to a variety of projects at
existing Hydro facilities that have
helped improve efficiencies so that
these plants are able to generate more
power and more renewable energy
certificates um these renewable energy
certificates have generally been class 4
but in a few cases have been class one
wrecks because the facilities were
either substantially overhauled um or in
one case was actually a new
facility
um I will say that we strongly agree
with the conclusions in the Doe's
November 2024 report that state in part
and I'm going to quote here as this
report illustrates demand for rebates
and Grant Awards continues to be strong
rebate and Grant funds have leveraged
over 460 million in private investment
providing a boost to the state's economy
and creating jobs for electricians
plumbers and Alternative Energy
businesses in addition there has been
substantial growth in distributed energy
generation uh renewable energy systems
that serve to diversify our energy
Supply reduce our reliance on fossil
fuels reduce greenhouse gas emissions
and increase our energy Independence so
we hope that the renewable energy funds
continue to be Ed for their intended
purpose and thank you for your time I
know I'm out of time Mr chairman I want
to say two very quick things one my
quick back of the envelope math is that
if there are $5 million in renewable
energy funds that translates into
0.4 per kwh or 0.4
per kwh on a rate of 17 cents which I
think is probably on the low side uh
that is a. 2% reduction um if you gave
all of that money back the other thing I
wanted to say there was a comment made
earlier that just go with a$ Z ACP that
will completely really wipe the RPS off
the books because no Lo load serving
entity is going to go out and buy a
wreck when they know they can just make
a z ACP so with that I'm happy to answer
any questions and I appreciate your time
thank you questions representative PL
has one uh thank you chair this is to
the chair could uh Miss Crow Supply
electronic of her testimony to us I'm
sure she would if we uh would like it so
yes consider yourself requested sure
absolutely yes uh representative
Harrington ask a question yeah thank you
thank you for taking my question so it
seems like what you're saying is that
your clients make more more money so
that someone who's let's say retired
lives in a small apartment on a fixed
income they're going to pay a higher
electric rate so your clients can make
more profits that's that's your
position um no my my position is that
the renewable uh energy fund is a
continually appropriated dedicated n
Ling fund that was created for a purpose
um and we think the RPS does serve an
important purpose um hydros participate
in in the RPS program um you may not
have been here the day that U madin
minow and I presented but um New
Hampshire hydr also serve a lot of other
important um Public Safety and societal
benefits um we maintain um and operate
many dams in New Hampshire with private
dollars um that are not um if those
costs weren't being borne by the private
sector they would be born by taxpayers
and we know that we have a substantial
problem in New Hampshire um with the
state-owned dams and trying to figure
out how to fund um maintenance and
operation of those so representative
Kaplan has a question thank you Mr chair
and thank you for coming in uh Miss
croll um you mentioned and your and at
the end of your comments that if the RPS
was to fold up based on you know
alternative compliance payments going
down to zero uh what effect would that
have on your membership and secondly
what effect would that have on the
state's ability to meet its energy needs
so um as we testif as we presented um we
uh came to your committee a couple weeks
ago in the granite state hydrop Power
Association and I testified um the RPS
revenue is an important Revenue stream
for the hydro facilities here in New
Hampshire again um we uh there are
requirements in the RPS about uh those
facilities their size their fist passage
requirements other um criteria that need
to be met um it's an important Revenue
stream given the
um uh expenses and the burdens
Regulatory and otherwise that Hydro
facilities um face and so um you know it
would be uh for some of the smaller ones
for sure it could be uh a significant
impact to lose that Revenue um I'm sorry
lost your second question what you
therefore what impact would that have on
our state's ability to meet its energy
needs um well I mean I think the
diversity
uh for New Hampshire is important it's
very important um and in keeping prices
low for consumers and also um you know
every little bit of Supply helps and in
the case of hydro um pretty much run 247
as long as there's uh run of river there
and for hydro facilities that have um uh
reservoirs they're able to run 247 using
that Reservoir so it's serves as um a
base load type um Supply as well as
peing when they have the
reservoir thank you Miss Groll we
appreciate your test testimony and next
I'll call on Charlie
nebling
yes did you have a question I did oh
representative McGee has a question I
guess thank you Mr chairman thank you
Miss croll um so what struck me about
your testimony is that you mentioned the
fact fact that um the low income low
income and competitive Grant programs
leverage private investment right so
it's a force multiplier for example and
then you mentioned that in the November
2024 RF report where you concluded that
or it concluded that demand is strong
you said that 460 million in private
investment had been um used as a result
of the fact that we have this RF program
uh as a catalyst
so uh it sounds to me as though this is
a program that um is doing what New
Hampshire has always tried to do well
which is Cobble
together uh programs that spend very
little but give us a much bigger benefit
and so I wonder if you could say
anything from your familiarity with the
small hydros you did mention briefly um
about some Investments that they had
made but if you could just talk about uh
the margins that these businesses have
because as you mentioned they're
providing us far more benefit by
maintaining things that would have to be
paid for another way right so it's a
complex issue it's not you'll get four
cents back and so that's good that's
better it's all these other things
you're trying to quantify so I would
like to understand a a little bit more
about the the amount of money that gets
invested in the state of New Hampshire
as a result of a program like
this so I yes I was quoting and this is
in the conclusion section of the um most
recent uh report that Doe put out on the
renewable energy fund and I think um you
heard that Mr Elliott is going to be
supplying that to the committee so it's
toward the end and what it indicated
that was that rebate and Grant funds
have leveraged over
46060 million in private investment so
that number is coming from them um I can
get you more details on the various um
facilities Hydro facilities that have um
so they compete um they submit an RFP uh
or a proposal in response to the RFP
that the department of energy puts out
um sometimes they're selected sometimes
they're not but a competitive process um
and then they um get a small amount of
money from the renewable energy fund
it's typically been you know in the
range of about maybe 125 to
$175,000 um um significantly leveraged
um with the hydro owner's own money um
to do these types of projects which um
one of the key things um for any of
projects that participate in any of
these programs is that um it has to the
project has to result in additional
renewable energy certificates so the
idea is that that is intended to
increase the supply of renewable energy
certificates to help bring down the cost
of compliance um so I hope that answers
your question a little bit and I can
follow up with you later thank you okay
next we'll hear from Charlie
nebling of
bosan haven't seen you in a while
welcome back
Charlie uh my name is Charlie nebling
I'm a
semi-retired Forester and renewable
energy
consultant I was quite involved in the
enactment of the RPS back in 2007 House
Bill a
73 and in particular in the in the um
specific um uh policy directives around
the adoption of a renewable energy fund
to be capitalized by alternative
compliance payments so I have some
history with the with the statute and
its implementation in the 16 or 17 years
now that it's been
functional I'm here opposed to the bill
today
um I don't I profess to not fully
understand the purpose of the bill at
least based on the the prime sponsor's
testimony and what the language of the
bill says they seem to be at somewhat at
odds I think
um I just to to representative
Harrington's uh question or comment
earlier and and Heidi spoke to this the
purpose of the fund is to support
renewable energy techn technologies that
generate
recks so that the compliance entities uh
the competitive suppliers and regulated
utilities are able to secure sufficient
recks in the marketplace to meet their
statutory obligation without having to
make an alternative compliance payment
so every one of the programs that the
department of energy and the Pu before
them have implemented are intended to
generate more wrecks into the
Marketplace and help the RPS fulfill its
purposes its public policy purposes I
just want to emphasize that and also
this fund and its source of funding is
virtually the same in every state that
has an RPS program something like 29
states have alternative compliance
mechanisms and then use that money to
help generate additional renewable
energy the last comment I'd like to make
Mr chairman is to remind the committee
that we we are I believe the second most
dependent state in the country in terms
of the proportion of energy met by
fossil fuels second only to Hawaii we
export three to four billion dollars a
year for the energy that we import
because we don't produce fossil fuels in
our state what we do produce is
renewable energy and every dollar that
goes to support in instate renewable
development is a dollar not being
exported to some other state or some
other country around the world and that
has a significant multiplier impact on
our state economy $ 3 to4 billion doll a
year is one and a. half to 2% of our
Gross State product so it's not
insignificant
um I'm surprised that the representative
of the Department of energy did not or
that a question was not asked about the
current fund balance in the renewable
energy fund it's actually over $20
million and I think a more appropriate
line of inquiry for the committee to
consider through this bill is how was
that fund allowed to acrw a $20 million
balance why was it not fully deployed to
its intended purposes and what more can
be done to make sure that it's expended
cost effectively to meet meet the goals
of the renewable portfolio standard it
seems to me that
ultimately far greater benefit will be
realized through that approach than
through the approach proposed by the
sponsor thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr nebling and Mr Elliott if you could
um get us information about the current
balance of the renewable energy fund
we'd appreciate that okay questions for
Mr
nebling seeing none we'll move move
along and get the perspective of clean
energy New Hampshire by inviting Sam
Evans Brown to give us his uh his take
on this
Bill thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Sam Evans Brown
executive director of clean energy New
Hampshire many of the points that I
would make have been made already so
I'll try to not repeat things that have
been said um I will just note that that
uh according to the 5-year dedicated
funds report that has been submitted uh
from the Department to the department
well uh that has been submitted I'll
just leave it as uh a uh uh um unclear
as to who submitted and where until I'm
sure uh year ending balance in 2022 was
9.6 million it grew to 15.3 million in
2023 and in 2024 it had expanded to 20.9
million we have been flagging this for
members of the fiscal committee for a
couple years now and the response that
we've heard from the Department of
energy is that ACP Revenue can be
unpredictable and so they didn't want to
overcommit uh I think it's pretty clear
that they've they've uh corrected in the
wrong direction and are not getting the
money out the door quickly enough I
would humbly agree with uh Mr nebling
that that the appropriate response here
is to ensure that the department of
energy is budgeting the appropriate
amount into the program as is intended
and in fact mandated by the statute that
governs the renewable energy fund and
the RPS um I will I will just say you
know this the RPS is intended to be a
self-balancing policy so when there are
not enough renewable energy credits
alternative compliance payments are paid
which then are which then fund new
projects that create more renewable
energy credits which then drives down
the cost of compliance with the RPS um
and and if you take away one part of
that mechanism the policy is simply not
going to work and RPS compliance costs
are simply going to rise uh and new
renewable energy generation is not going
to be not going to be built so uh the
the two really work hand inand um I
would also note I did my own back of the
napkin math uh my my maths show that for
the average residential rate payer in
New Hampshire the RPS compliance costs
around $5 a year which I don't think are
the thing that is the thing that's going
to make people move to New Hampshire or
not based on based on the energy costs
uh certainly New England does have H
very high uh electricity rates I would
argue that the our sort of fundamental
geography are what drive that the lack
of resources here for us to take
advantage of the lack of infrastructure
to deliver that energy to New Hampshire
and so going after programs like this is
not going to solve the problem and the
last thing i' note is that while the
costs of the RPS are very clearly
enumerated uh you know and are in fact
laid out in many regulatory filings uh
the benefits are nowhere are not
enumerated anywhere so we had a long
Bill hearing previously about the cost
benefit tests of the new H save program
the RPS doesn't doesn't have such a test
we simply have an accounting of the
costs with no accounting of the benefits
and all of these renewable energy
projects that get built have benefits to
our to our electricity prices they
depress Regional wholesale prices on the
market and if we were to eliminate these
resources from our grid mix electricity
rates would likely Rise by some
indeterminate amount that we have never
accounted for so um this is a very
modest program this is a very small
amount of money you're not going to make
a huge difference in anyone's lives by
rebating it back to them you will uh
have a a devastating impact on many pro
uh projects that are relying on these
funds uh and it's unclear why that's a
good idea I'll just note uh New
Hampshire clean en New Hampshire has our
energy circuit Riders program which are
sort of pro bono technical assistant
that work on behalf of municipalities to
help them do energy projects that will
save their taxpayers money we are aware
of over a hundred Municipal solar
projects that are in the works right now
many of which have been have started to
advance because they knew that funding
was available through the renewable
energy fund the department of energy has
repeatedly signaled that they're going
to be taking this money and creating a
new competitive Municipal solar grant
program uh and so those projects are
advancing on the understanding that
those funds are going to be available uh
and like I said there's there's over a
hundred of them now that we're tracking
so with that I think I will take any
questions that the committee might have
okay Vice chair Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh by what basis did
you use to come over that $5 a year
Savings in terms of uh how many kilowatt
hours per month did you use and what was
rate saving so the average New Hampshire
residential rate pair uses 660 kilowatt
hours a month and so when you when you
take the the numbers that Heidi croll uh
brought up earlier which are from the
the filings that that um that the
utilities make regarding the cost of RPS
compliance it's around you know 03 cents
per kilowatt hour times 660 I think is
the the you know that may be off a tiny
bit uh like I said back of the
napkin okay seeing no further questions
we want to thank you for being here and
next we'll call on Jason stock of the
Timberland Owners Association to give us
his perspective on
this good morning and welcome back to
stn haven't seen you in a while it's
been a while well good morning um some
new faces of I'll be really brief
because I know you're crunched for time
but for the record I'm Jason stock I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire Timberland Owners Association
we represent the forest products
industry Timberland owners and um I've
come today to to speak in opposition to
this bill we actually have members that
small business members that actually
participate in these programs I can name
three off the top of my head Britain
Lumber and bath they put in a biomass a
biomass boiler to generate heat for
their dry killing operation for them
it's a great fit because it utilizes a
sawmill waste product they make the logs
into Lumber they chip the slabs they
they are part participating it DCI a man
a lumber or excuse me a furniture
manufacturer up in the Littleton area
and then the third is is Middleton
building supplier depro Pine sales over
in Middleton um which is out near Alton
they have a biomass boiler I think they
also put in some solar as well to kind
of uh augment their their power supply
and so to that end I'll I'm not going to
repeat what you've heard the last three
speakers did an awesome job at kind of
encapsula in the whole point of this the
self-balancing ACT I was there
participating in the when the the RPS
was developed and and Mr Evans Brown did
a great job at articulating it but
affordability and reliability we are not
immune well we are not ignorant of that
or not looking at that as as small
businesses but when we look at
reliability we also look at the need for
energy diversity to put all our eggs in
a particular basket whether it's natural
gas wind whatever you're not going to
have the reliability and that's where we
get the crazy energy swings that we've
seen over the last couple years when
there are shortages of one Supply or the
other the whole one of the key points of
the RPS and the whole mechanism behind
it was to to promote energy diversity in
the state and local homegrown power and
so with that that I'll just say when
when you look at affordability and
reliability there is an intersection
there but with reliability one of the
key elements of that is having fuel
diversity with that I'll conclude my
testimony and I appreciate your time
this morning thank
you okay thank you very much I have a
quick question for you yes I know you've
been around this business a long time
watching people burn wood for to at
heat can you give us a some kind of a an
idea of why we need an incentive to get
people to use wood boilers in their
businesses and their uh larg
institutional buildings if it's a good
energy source and it's a good renewable
energy source why do we need to provide
incentives to people to adopt it well in
and as you heard in some of the other
examples given before particularly on
the community side you you know these
programs help bring that Capital cost
down they help bring that c that initial
Capital cost down so that it's that it's
more competitive in in on a More Level
Playing Field with some of the other
energy sources so we see these programs
as kind of taking that initial sting
particularly out of that initial Capital
cost um we look at project like the
Rockingham County nursing home that has
a a biomass boiler and how those
programs you know for for the citizens
of Rockingham County or a school to
float a bond it's a pretty and I've been
on a school board and suffered through
those meetings when you're asking for a
bond for whatever to have something like
this that can tip the scale and and
really help push a project move a
project forward particularly if you're
changing a fuel source if you'd always
been burning oil or natural gas this is
kind of a new thing for some folks
although I will admit burning Wood's
been around as long as there's been
people but it is a new thing and so this
helps kind of tip that scale and so to
answer your question I think it's it's a
competitive thing but I think it's also
it helps with the financing particularly
with that Capital cost right up
front so my followup would be are you
saying that the capital cost for wood
Oilers is higher than the capital cost
for like an oil or a gas fired oh boy
you're you're testing my my knowledge
I'd have to take a look at that I know
the
infrastructure I'd have to I'd have to
dive into the and i' I'd defer to Mr
nebling who's a wood boiler I'll call
him Guru um I defer to him in terms of
comparing Capital cost for for wood
versus uh other sources of energy okay
I'll talk to Mr fr ring and Mr Mr Fring
too of course other questions for U Mr
stock seeing none I'll thank you Jason
for being here and call next on
Jared mullner I believe I pronounced
that correctly he's either representing
himself or representing something called
IM
Sy main sis he is from Auburn Maine
misus yes thank you chairman and the
committee I wanted to talk a little bit
about America's first heating fuel wood
uh and how it has changed we have been
heating for it since heating with wood
forever um and it has changed its shape
and size a little bit as it's been
refined throughout the last 100 years a
few hundred years that we've been using
it and into the forms of chips and
pellets um and when you do refine that
to utilize it for heating uh the
equipment cost that are going to be burn
that uh does have a higher Capital
outlay than a traditional fuel um the
company that I work for there represents
thousands of people in New Hampshire
that have trucks driving to their homes
just like Oil Trucks but happen to
contain wood pellets they have hoses
that latches on the outside of your
house and will blow pellets into these
pellet storage bins or your new oil tank
and then convey the the pellets to a
heating system to heat your entire home
with wood pellet fuel or wood chip fuel
so the refinement of America's first
fuel of wood has happened and is here
and these um rebates help offset the
capital cost so that there are lots of
people in New Hampshire that have taken
advantage of that would like to and it's
sort of that seesaw instability of the
funding of if it's there that you know
has prevented and been a problem uh for
people to make the switch and um I would
just like to make sure that there is
stability so that they're known that
there is money available and there's not
any stoppages of the program uh in the
future for all these customers that
would like to burn America's first fuel
first heating fuel thank
you okay thank you very much
questions representative partiall has
one thank you chair and thank you for
being here today um you mentioned that
um our new technology is higher Capital
Clause could you also maybe address I
don't know if it's true or not they have
over the uh period of time they have
higher recovery cost on what
they're yeah that is the reason why we
you're having people that want to do the
fuel switching uh higher capital outlay
for a more stable lower cost fuel in the
long run so so I would argue the person
who talked about his high efficiency gas
boiler earlier that testified in the
long run he'll probably pay a lot
significant more with the fuel that he's
chosen to replace and use in his home
thank you representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for being with us today so if this bill
passed um and the renewable energy fund
ceased to exist how would that impact
businesses like yours that are looking
to assist people with this transition th
those that want to participate in it
quite a bit um you know it's they're
still outlaying quite a bit of cash and
and deeming it worthy to do so because
the rebates are probably only about a
third but it would it would drastically
reduce the people that would want to do
it followup and you also mentioned the a
prior um testimony talking about a high
efficiency burner that was on a fossil
fuel and you said he's probably going to
end up paying more in the long R could
you say a little bit about the fact
uh say a little bit about the economics
of people that we're trying to help with
public private Investments here uh in
terms of the long run yeah of course
well that's why you've seen places like
the Dublin School uh you know uh White
Mountain School you've seen these
municip IP alties switch because it is a
lowcost stable fuel that they can kind
of pencil in what it's going to cost for
a while there without the DraStic
fluctuations that there would be in
fossil fuels um I think speaks to the
locality of it I mean we're not in Texas
we don't have oil indigenous to New
Hampshire but we do have trees that are
here and uh that should be and could be
utilized
um more than they already are in order
to help heat the homes and keep the cost
down and keep the local money here in
the economy as what would happen if we
used what we have here for resources in
New Hampshire to
heat well thank you m Mr Muller I'm
going to call on thank you for your
testimony I'm going to call on Meredith
Hatfield from the nature Conservatory
Conservatory H long morning uh welcome m
thank
you uh good morning and I would remind
you you have the same time limit as
everyone else yes thank you very much
I'm Meredith Hatfield for The Nature
Conservancy um we uh also oppose this
bill and we agree with many of the
points that have already been made so I
will try not to be repetitive um you've
heard about the types of Technologies
the types of projects that the fund has
supported these projects aren't just
good for the OWN owners and the
residents of the host municipalities but
they can also help to reduce our need
for energy from the regional electric
grid which is particularly helpful in
times like this when um costs are so
high and so
volatile um and that helps make us less
dependent on um other energy sources
from around the region um I wanted to
call two things to your attention that
have been referenced um the annual
report um from November 1st of last year
from the Department of energy I believe
was submitted to the committee but it's
also available on the doe uh website I
provide the link um to that in our
letter and also um uh Mr Evans Brown
referred to um the renewable energy fund
dedicated funds report these are
provided from agencies to the Department
of administrative Services they're also
available online and what I'll do is um
I'll include that with my testimony when
I upload it uh later today and um I
agree we agree with um Mr nebling that a
question that you really should be
considering is why the fund had a
balance of over $20 million last June
30th um especially when in its report uh
the doe talks about all the
successes and says demand for rebates
and Grant Awards continues to be strong
um so we think it would be more
appropriate to spend the funds for their
intended purpose as Miss koll said it is
a dedicated fund of rate payer money
that should be used for its intended
purpose um the other point is that
rather than undermining the RPS and the
purposes of the renewable energy fund
and failing to invest in Innovation and
energy Independence it actually would be
more consistent with some of the other
policy bills that you're considering
this year looking at how to ensure that
New Hampshire is innovative um to it
would actually be more consistent to
maintain this funding and continue to
make it available uh to New Hampshire
customers including businesses residents
institutions and towns um we would
request that you either find this bill
in expedient to legislate or if you
would like to explore these issues to
amend the bill to become a study
committee to consider them further thank
you thank you questions for Miss
Hatfield representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
Miss Hatfield for coming in uh one of
the initiatives that would be struck
down by uh the bill would be the office
of offshore wind initiatives I'm not
sure if that's the exact right title but
uh can you comment
on what that would do to our energy uh
diversity and our you know overall the
overall meeting our overall energy needs
in coming decades if if that office
wasn't there that's off topic of the
subject of the bill it's in the bill
it's it's the the lines that are struck
from the bill are include the office of
offshore wind somebody else mentioned it
okay my mistake I'll allow it um thank
you representative Kaplan you know fuel
diversity is an important aspect of the
both the RPS and
thef um you know prior speakers did
refer to the recent executive order at
the federal level uh pausing offshore
wind um so we may not see much
investment in that area but continuing
to have an office of innovation At Doe I
think really makes sense and it could
support uh the committee's continued
investigation into modular nuclear and
you know other Technologies as they
become
available additional questions seeing
none thank you and um final word goes to
Mr cof of the conservation law
Foundation good morning again um thanks
for having me up here a second time my
name is Nick cof with the conservation
law Foundation I'm a senior attorney
there I'm here to testify an opposition
to HP 224 um this bill would essentially
eliminate the renewable energy fund but
rebating these funds to rate payers
would only result in Trivial benefits to
them um as has been mentioned each year
the department of energy comes out with
a renewable energy fund annual report
great read uh recommend anybody reading
it that hasn't already um but the report
provides some information on the total
costs of alternative compliance payments
which you know we've heard fund the the
fund um now based on the information in
the report if the entire renewable
energy fund had been rebated to Electric
rays in
2023 the average residential customer
would have received a rebate of only 34
cents per month in 2023 so the
calculations are explained in my written
testimony which been um handed around
but it's based on table four in the um
report so 34 cents that's what we're
talking about here really per month
um so in other words rebating the
renewable energy fund is going to result
in negligible benefits for rap payers
but now now I want to shift my attention
a little bit to the benefits of the fund
um you as it's already mentioned the
report says that the the fund boosts the
state economy creates jobs for
electricians plumbers um energy
businesses but you know it's also
benefited schools and towns um providing
them rebates and grants and in 2024 a
grant was awarded to Raymond High School
to fund a biomass heating system and so
if we eliminate the fund towns and
schools and the people in those towns
the kids that go to those schools you
know they're they're going to be hurt
because they're not going to have um
this money available to fund you know
these much-needed Energy Systems um as
also is detailed in the report the the
fund funds um low-income projects for
for low-income customers um so customers
live in manufactured housing or that
live in multif family rental housing
just by for an example in 2024 the fund
um helped finance a project undertaken
by New Hampshire Catholic Charities um
that will benefit 59 households and
results in each household receiving $300
a year in benefits so in conclusion um
getting rid of the fund is going to
result in close to nothing in benefits
for the average residential rapair or
any Rays for that matter but it will
harm those towns and um and schools that
rely on it to help to help fund the
energy systems they need to do um as
well as the contractors and businesses
that uh that do that work um and the
low-income folks too that that benefit
from those programs um thank you very
much happy to answer any of your
questions questions representative MC
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Koff
for being here um what struck me as you
were speaking is that uh one of the
things we're not really discussing is
rebating the money that's in the program
and basically extinguishing the program
uh rather than keeping it in its
intended uh
state is a one-time thing right it's a
one-time very small negligible amount of
money to people whereas the Investments
continue beyond just getting people over
the hump of being able to put those in
right the the Investments end up
lowering costs for towns and Facilities
that are making these investments into
into the future correct well yeah so
there's a so MoneyWise there's a if
you're looking at cost benefit I guess
the that's the question is that these
Investments ments are not just this
money is not just giving us um the
ability to get over the hump of making
the initial investment it is also
allowing people to lower their costs
into the future yeah I mean absolutely I
mean if you look at the Raymond High
School example you know that that boiler
system that they've installed or
installing you know that's going to
benefit them for decades and decades and
you know going to be a lot of benefits
for that for that school
district okay seeing no more questions I
want to thank you for your testimony and
I'm going to close the public hearing on
House Bill 224 FN and I'm going to ask
everyone to exit the room as quickly as
possible we have a republican caucus
immediately uh following uh the recess
of our committee for lunch so everybody
please exit the room and we'll see you
back here at 1:00 or possibly a little
later
e
e e
seats we're going to begin
shortly e
okay welcome back to science technology
and energy for Monday December the uh
27th or January the 27th of 2025 forgot
my month so we are scheduled for three
public hearings this afternoon at 1:00 I
scheduled HB
436 establishing a commission to solicit
reports and testimony
regarding unidentified anomalous
phenomena in the state and then at 2:00
I've scheduled HB
627 relative to permitting the Public
Utilities Commission to approve
providers for the lifeline
program and then at 2:30 I scheduled HP
46- FN relative to utility investments
in distributed energy
resources and
and so since our first public hearing is
at
1:00 for HB
436 I'd like to like to get a sense from
the committee about how we should
proceed because there is no one here to
introduce this
legislation so what are our options well
the first option is we could open the
public
hearing and then close the public
gearing here
here um another option would be
to take a 1- hour recess and come back
at
2:00 I could open the um public hearing
and recess it
until a later
time anybody have any ideas rep Vice
chair Thomas Mr chairman uh it it's
obviously that this U bill was uh
scheduled properly and it is in the
calendar for a 1:00 start and uh
President says that we can appoint uh
there being no Prime sponsor or
co-sponsor here present uh we can
appoint a member from the committee to
in us the bill and then see if there are
any pink sheets if there are none uh my
recommendation will be uh public hearing
should be closed
representative nter thank you Mr chair I
agree with the vice chairman also this
came up in another committee I believe
it was criminal justice there was a bill
that uh the prime sponsor didn't show up
and he had no co-sponsors I don't know
what they did though with that
hearing how many people would actually
like to discuss the substance of the
bill I'm sure everybody's read it um
does anybody feel compelled to dis
discuss it looks like we have one person
who would be willing to discuss it I
don't know if you can have a discussion
with um with more than one person have
a did you intend sir to submit a pink
card to testify on this
bill no one here unfortunately we have
no one here who knows anything about it
so
we do and and part of the reason I'm
wrestling with this is because we have a
rule in the house that says every bill
must have a public
hearing so I would like to have a public
hearing but if there's nobody here to
talk about the bill how can you have a
public hearing representative plog uh
thank you chair uh it has been mentioned
one option was one of us could introduce
the bill and if we have someone here
wants to hear or speak on it and then
from there on we can treat it as a
regular Bill and I'm willing to um
introduce the bill let me read it over
again Mr chair all right representative
Wendy Thomas thank you
um if you are brave enough to introduce
this bill are you also brave enough to
take questions on
it go ahead thank you um yes I I have I
have had input on this from last session
if you could remember of contrails I
pronounced that right and things like
that and uh people had brought things to
my attention which I will bring
forth all right I guess we have uh
something with which we can go forward
so let's go ahead and open the public
hearing then on House Bill
436 establishing a commission to solicit
reports and test Tony regarding
unidentified anomalous phenomena in the
state and I'll call on representative PL
to introduce the bill and if anybody
would like to speak on the bill please
fill out and submit a pink card on the
bill so representative CL do your
best thank you question to the chair
before I start um in
so when I do this I won't be asking or
interacting with anyone once I go back
for
questions no because you're you're not
the um the prime sponsor I think that
I'll wave that rule for for you for this
uh for this hearing if anybody shows up
okay so go ahead thank you um I'm
introducing House Bill
436 U since there is no sponsors
available I'm just going to skip over
I'm assuming we all has read this to the
duties and this is why I'm up here
speaking right now to the duties of the
bill is to seek out people who
witnessed phenomena on that they can't
explain aerial
phenomena I had interactions with people
who claim I had shared where long ago I
have a question sighting that um with
physics I cannot
explain that was many in the 1970s I
don't have the details anymore other
than I have witnessed something now we
have
citizens be it one or a
thousand who have come before us with
things in the sky we had no uh New
Jersey of late of mystery drones flying
around and is no one right now who can
take testimony or
evidence whatever it may be so this
seems to set up a three
member
commission that will
meet I believe uh what is it four times
a
year
um I think four or three times a year to
take in informations and discuss what
they
received I'm going forward with
introducing this because of I do have
interactions of mostly the contrails and
other phenomena like that which when it
was brought to my attention to go online
where they have flight
trackers and there are planes flying
over New Hampshire that are not showing
up on flight tractors
for whatever reason and at the same time
reporting of um cond condensation Trails
so what are they we don't know because
there's no committee at this point to
look at it I I think that's my whole
understanding I have not spoken with any
of the sponsors so with
that I'll try to take
questions good luck with that so the
first question I would have is
is chapter
12-q a new chapter because I'm looking
at on the
U on the state well I did a Google
search on New New Hampshire RSA chapter
12 and I don't see a chapter Q I see
chapter p and I see a chapter
12 new chapter
so this is a new chapter well wouldn't a
new chapter need to Define what
anomalous phenomena are and this bill
doesn't do that this is not really a
question I'm just thinking out loud and
and at this point I don't see any point
in US asking questions since we don't
have anyone really who can answer them
so let's just have a quick discussion I
mean if we recess this public hearing
we're just going to sit around and
twiddle our thumbs till 2 o' anyway
so I haven't received a pink card so I
have nobody else who wants to speak on
this bill at this
point so let's just have a discussion
Vice chair
Thomas well I was going to com thank you
Mr chairman I was going to comment on on
your on your last comment that uh we
would just sit here and twit our thumbs
I was going to make a recommendation
that if we have some spare time we could
use that time to discuss a potential
list of um field trips that we that we
could be planning for in the spring uh
so that we could at least get working on
uh getting with the lobbyist and and and
getting things organized to start on
that so if we if we if we do have the
time we could employ our time in that
manner would be my suggestion point of
order who has a point of order I do uh
introduction uh that does not concern
this bill um so if I'm done testim
testifying oops yes you you can you can
go back to your
seat oh representative na ner has a
question what happened to the term UFO
unidentified flying object why did they
change it to unidentified anomalous
phenomena that has been changed I
believe with the military so they could
report it in their vernacular that if I
correct they are the ones who actually
changed
that and now it's become follow
up there's no Emoji for uh a UAP there's
only an emoji for
UFO it's not a question they must be
behind
times sir
we representative
Bernardi I believe the predominant
reason for going with anomalous
phenomenon rather than unidentified
flying objects is some of these quote
unquote sightings are uh entities that
go both in the water and in the
air representative
Swanson um excuse me a while back the
Air Force Air Force had a uh UFO hot
line uh it was changed recently to
unidentified anomolous object and it
would seem like uh this something like
this would be redundant to that at least
as far as in the
air okay who's next uh representative
Harrington I just uh just because
someone comes up with an idea doesn't
mean we should even be considering it as
a bill I mean what does this got to do
with the function of the state New
Hampshire and our authority to go after
UFOs I mean I I just think this is a
total waste of time and
effort representative Wendy Thomas um
thank you and
I I think this question was was answered
by uh a previous uh representative
comment but you when you introduced the
bill you were talking about aerial
phenomena and yet in in line seven it
talks about the skies and territories
and I think I just heard that this also
includes water and is
there so it's very Broad in its in its
application is that
correct I would I would
Define your question as being correct
not writing this bill I also have
questions I am introducing it
because citizens have asked these
questions in front of us before
and I think it should have been brought
up and that's why I'm bringing up that
there are constituents out there for
whatever they do have
concerns uh representative Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chairman I have a
question for the chairman I because of a
previous comment are we in a question
mode to the introductory person or are
we in a discussion mode where we can
bring up General discussions um and
should we release the spe the uh the uh
the kind representative to go back to a
seat I did try to release him a little
while ago but so you you are released
thank you
chair but let's continue our discussion
representative parial thank you chair I
want many un record I'm this is the
first I'm the first person to agree from
our side with a representative
Herrington this
year um but I do want to ask um I'm not
this is more of a question for the
entire committee I've never seen a bill
that has three members of the house and
no members of the
Senate yeah and a commission doesn't
that doesn't list any other members this
is unusual for me it is very unusual and
and also it's a commission rather than a
study committee commissions usually have
outside
members yeah commissions are permanent
unless they have a an explicit end date
which this one does not can have members
outside the house right commissions can
also have members from outside the
house representative Corman um so given
that we have no more witnesses is are we
still in a public hearing or is or
should it be
closed that's a good question maybe um
maybe I'll call the clerk and ask him if
we can have a discussion about a bill if
there's nobody to testify actually I
have a follow-up question and the
followup would be um I know in uh the
last session if the chair and ranking
member agreed to exec a bill uh at any
time then the bill could be exact and
I'm wondering is that still the rule and
uh would the chair and ranking member be
interested in executing this bill
now I can ask the clerk about that that
is the rule however you have to put in
the calendar when you have a public
hearing the disclaimer that a public
hearing may happen at any time and and
we didn't do that executive session
rather yeah and we didn't do that so I'm
not sure we could do that today but I'll
ask the clerk and
um so let's just uh hang on for a minute
while I contact the clerk
yeah some of these
that's why got flying and
they're getting they're getting a ride
with the
alien I've sent a text to the house
Clerk and I'm waiting for a response
okay I just got a response from the
clerk he says someone should introduce
the bill formally well we've done that
if you want to discuss it you should go
into
exec all right so now let me say we did
not notice
that it's anomalous
phenomenon stirring stirring
oh Yeti there yeah Yeti I can spell that
they have
one
Disneyland e
so representative Corman
the the um answer to your question is no
that part of the rule was repealed
according to the
clerk so we can't just do it unless we
notice it ahead of time so I will try to
include that notice in all future public
hearing notices of the committee so that
we can do that if it h if this happens
again so CL he did not answer my
question about whether oh yes he did if
we want to discuss it we have to go EXA
we have to go into an exact but we can't
go into exec so I guess we're done done
this public hearing is closed
we will now be on recess until 2
o'clock uh I'm open to suggestions if
people want to start talking about um
where we might want to go come
springtime um I nominate representative
Madson to take notes on on where where
we we might want to go since I believe
she will be heading
it representative n thank you Mr
chairman we have not been to Army arm
RMI that would be really cool and also
uh
segue the segue Factory oh okay those
are good suggestions Army is the
advanced regenerative medicine
Institute representative parshall
okay other suggestions for field
trips
Rita I would love to go to ISO New
England ISO New
England always a popular trip lengthy
but
popular seab
brooken and don't we under
oh my gosh about that gr count on no no
discussion of bers please take that
offline so another possibility is
Granite State Hydro Power Association
has invited us to visit a Hydro power
facility representative parial sorry I
should have thank thank you for your
Indulgence I would suggest Maybe a
specific one it's in marbor it's rather
impressive it's a short walk and it's
pretty amazing what they're doing there
and at the same time they have pack
badok not far away that's been
recommended by one of the people that
testified here is a communication Tower
and the U weather instrumentation wasn't
particularly robust yes that was ISO no
wingland I and there's one other place
that I would suggest in that area which
I find very fasinating personally is
trolling uh energy and trolling energy
is another oneing
o yes yeah exactly so Pacman adok is
where New Hampshire Dees has a
monitoring station yeah okay Doug
representative Thomas Doug Thomas uh
it's it's it's been a while uh but we
could also do a trip to the uh natural
gas power plant in lary run formerly run
by Calpine I believe they're recently
being sold um and while we're there we
could take a a very short side trip to
to another weather uh indicator station
that's also located in lunder as well so
we could kill two birds Mr chairman Mr
chairman yes uh representative McGee um
several of us as part of clean energy
week went over to um the facility oh not
my mind is going blank but um Granite
Shore power has a facility over on the
Sea Coast where they're putting in
batteries as well as doing the same uh
in Shilling yeah I couldn't Schiller
couldn't think of it um so I would I
would like to see if we could get a tour
of Schiller station because they had
some really interesting things going on
there and they had some really uh
qualified people to answer questions for
those of you that were there you
probably remember uh about what they're
trying to do so I would I would put that
one on the
list Granite sh power Granite Shore
power representative Corman
yeah um so this would not be something
for the whole committee but actually
something that I'm going to be doing
during the break that we have at the end
of February is that representative Manos
and I are going to Weirton West Virginia
to the form energy battery Factory
that's the company that makes the iron
air batteries that are going to be the
basis of the 8.5 gwatt hour facility in
Maine and I'd asked um uh Sarah Jackson
when when we saw her a few months ago if
I could get a tour and we're going to go
get a tour uh I'd be pleased to report
back please take lots of pictures so we
can I asked about that and they said uh
they might be able to provide me some
photos but they might not be keen on me
taking
photos proprietary information after
all another possibility is the
eversource control room it's um an an
impressive uh facility not quite on the
order of Iona England but nevertheless
uh impressive and it's very local it
it's in Manchester so it's not a long
trip and it
controls the sector that we care most
about which is the state of New
Hampshire right so you'll get a chance
to talk to engineers and get much more
personal you'll get more personal
attention there than you will at ISO New
England in terms of being in the pit and
talking to people that actually operate
as well so it's very it's very
beneficial representative Wendy Thomas
thank you um I have had the great
opportunity to um go to Mount Washington
twice now um and they've put up um at
least I think there seven to nine new
weather stations on the east side of the
the mountain and they're doing a great
job monitoring weather and and
predicting and and that could be a good
one it's fascinating
okay other
suggestions I think that's a pretty
substantial list that you have there
so we should be free to start doing some
trips maybe in
April certainly by
May and we wouldn't do anything after
June 30th because
no noile you get no mileage after June
30th
so all right is there anything else the
committee would like to discuss between
now and two
o'clock okay you're free to go just be
back at 2 o'clock thank
you
e
e e
notice we will start in one
minute e
okay we'll get
started welcome members to um science
technology and energy today we are going
to be discussing HB 46- FN relative to
utility investments in distributed
energy resources with that I declare the
public hearing open and invite
representative o to introduce the bill
thank you uh Vice chair Thomas one quick
corre correction the bill we're hearing
is House Bill
627 relative to permitting the Public
Utilities Commission to approve new
providers for the lifeline program my ER
it got switched
okay so for the record I'm
representative Michael Vose and I
represent Rockingham District 5 and it's
my pleasure to introduce House Bill 627
it's a fairly simple bill it expands the
providers of a federal government
program that's been around since the
late 1980s called Lifeline
Services Lifeline Services has a variety
of
advantages mostly for lowincome
people it's an affordable
an better way to contact a health care
provider for example it would support
tele medicine which will help people
stay out of emergency rooms when they
need Primary
Care it provides better access to remote
learning opport opportunities through
the internet internet hotspots
Etc it provides better access to
emergency First Responders 911 services
and it also provides affordable access
to broadband and Wireless
Communications that can help people find
a job keep a
job deal with what's increasingly a
complex
economy so this is a bill that expands
opportunity for lower
income New Hampshire
citizens and it doesn't cost us anything
no State money is recovered not required
to support this
bill this bill the Lifeline Services and
and the other services that are provided
by this bill are actually funded by
federal Universal service fund fees USF
fees which if you look closely is on
your monthly cell phone
bill so we all fund this
program through our cell phone bills no
additional monies will be NE necess NE
AR and having more lifeline providers in
New Hampshire will enable more New
Hampshire citizens to have affordable
access to a variety of
services the bill itself is is based on
legislation that was recently passed in
the state of Maine it uses the
essentially the same language just
modified for New Hampshire and it allows
the public service utility uh commission
rather to uh
designate mobile commercial commercial
mobile service providers or Tel
Communications companies to be a carrier
for the purposes of receiving Universal
service support so it's a fairly simple
Bill and passage of this legislation
will reclaim New Hampshire's Authority
from the federal
government to allow the feds to keep
Soul control to to designate which
lifeline
telecommu
um I'm sorry I misread
that so passage of this legislation
reclaims New Hampshire's Authority from
the federal
government to keep sole control over
design designating which Lifeline
telecommun telecommunications companies
operate in our state by passing this
bill New Hampshire's POC can for the
first time make this
decision and the lower income citizens
in our state many who are seniors and
Veterans will benefit because they will
have affordable and better access to
wireless and Broadband
services and with that I'd be happy to
take
questions representative Wendy
Thomas didn't mean to but oh okay um
actually the the the ranking member had
a question before me should she go first
yeah well okay I saw one hand that's why
he was oh okay thank you thank you
thanks everybody and thank you Mr
chairman for your testimony so I have a
question it sounds like we're um the
Bill's maybe primary purpose is to shift
Authority so that we're able to
determine who would be eligible um to be
yeah it says in here uh eligible that
they would be become an eligible
telecommunications carrier so do we have
any idea who would be affected because
it seems like maybe the major service
carriers that we have in the state are
already in that category and already
have this program so who is it for
basically who who does it
help it doesn't
help to use your terminology any te
telecommunications vendor it just gives
the state The Authority that the federal
government has to determine who those
carriers might be so right now New
Hampshire is one of only five states in
the entire country that do not have this
Authority and in the last two years four
other states Maine Florida Virginia
Tennessee and Alabama unanimously passed
similar bills to change their laws to
reclaim this Authority from the FCC so
basically what we're doing here is
reclaiming from the FCC the authority
over these Lifeline service
providers representative Winnie Thomas
thank you uh Mr Vice chair um thank you
for introducing this bill and uh for
taking my question um on line three it
says that the commission may designate
any commercial mobile service provider
or Telecom telecommunications company
and then in line seven it says
designated as an eligible uh
telecommunications carrier my my
question is with that word any
commercial mobile service provider so
there are no qualifications or
standardizations for these providers
there's no criteria to be
one not sure I understand that
question I think what this language
basically means is that on lines three
and
four it's up to the commission to decide
who to
designate and in
lines six and
seven uh there may be already some who
have been
designated by the federal government so
this extends that designation ability to
the commission follow
up follow up thank you you um so does
the Pu who you say designates these
carriers do they have a list of criteria
that these carriers must meet in order
to be designated I think that's my
question oh now I understand the
question I don't believe so um because
the criteria I think are designated
under the US statutary codes that are
listed on line8 in the bill
thank
you represent Corman you have a question
thank you Mr Vice chair thanks for
taking my question um where did the idea
for this come from I know you said other
states are doing this but um how did he
get get into your
head so last summer I was attending a
conference of legislators from all
across the country and Senator Judson
Hill from the state of Georgia
approached me and suggested to me that
because New Hampshire is one of only
five states that do not have this
Authority that we
consider uh adopting this Authority or
reclaiming this
Authority he Senator Hill has sort of
made it a life project of his to help
get Lifeline Services to the entire you
know all the citizens of the United
States he was behind the move uh to
adopt this program in the state of Maine
he even went to the state of Maine and
testified before their legislature he
volunteered to come here and testify
before our legislature but I suggested
that um that probably wouldn't be
necessary because there's nothing but
upside to this bill there's no downside
to this bill
can't wa okay representative Winnie
Thomas thank you just point of
clarification what was that gentleman's
name Jud Hill Judson Hill senat Senator
Judson Hill from Georgia thank
you okay see no more questions thank you
representative
VES
yeah yes I did represent represent
Berard please ask your question thank
you youbody shair um so it's my
understanding that the little fee line
on our uh on our bill that uh pays for
this we will'll now just be transferring
money that the that the that was
collected and went to the feds now comes
to us so there's no there's no net
change in any costs no no this fee is
collected from the entire country yeah
so you're paying it
already but the Monies to fund the
lifeline program come from this fee it
covers other things as well thank
you representative
Harrington thank you and thank you for
taking my question so in a nutshell what
they're doing here is we have an
existing program that works for landline
phones and has for a number of years and
we're saying now well some people don't
have a landline phone anymore so they're
they're only using a cell phone and cell
phones aren't eligible and unless we
pass this legislation so it's basically
expanding the existing landline service
to Encompass cell phones as well that is
correct okay thank and some of those
same people who don't have a landline
phone also don't have a computer and
internet access so all they have is a
cell phone so that's their single point
of contact with the what we all know to
be a fairly complex economy
represent
partial Thank You Cher um it sounds like
a splendid idea I'm curious though um
will this affect the carrier of Last
Resort in any way it sounds like it make
may make the carrier of Last Resort more
affordable option through a cell phone
but I'm not sure of
that that's a separate designation from
being designated a
Lifeline support carrier so I wouldn't
expect that it would have any effect on
it okay thank
you okay being no other questions thank
you representative OES I'll call on M
Reagan Megan Stone from Department of
energy as our next
speaker thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee uh for the record my
name is Megan Stone legislatively a on
with the Department of energy it's great
to see you all again this afternoon um
so the department is neutral on House
Bill
627 um but there I would like to just
point out a couple things there is a
long-standing practice for the state to
defer to the FCC to designate
telecommunications providers as eligible
Communications telecommunications
carriers through that they're able to
receive Universal service support
including um the federally funded
Lifeline program which provides a
discount on um on the bill there are
currently no hurdles or obstacles for
providers to be approved as eligible
telecommunications carriers by the FCC
um should this Duty change to the Pu the
department does not believe it will
guarantee more carriers will offer a
Lifeline discount to customers um and as
New Hampshire does not have a state
Universal service program the FCC may be
better suited to making this decision um
and the current practice of the
department Fields has been
efficient that's all I have for you
today if there's any questions happy to
take those okay thank you any questions
for Miss
Stone representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um there's been some
discussion about how this would um not
affect us financially because we're just
essentially transferring money from the
feds to New Hampshire is there any other
application that is covered under that
money that might be lost if we if we do
this transfer specifically for this
program I don't believe so thank
you representative
Harrington yeah thank you for taking my
question um I just want to make sure I'm
straight on this so right now there are
no cell phone companies in New Hampshire
that can provide this uh Lifeline
Service uh that I that I am not entirely
sure if there are no cell phone
companies that can provide it I if they
can apply through the FCC to be
designated as a carrier um the state is
just not doing that okay followup follow
up well so I I guess what I'm hearing
then is that this simply says now the
state will have the authority to do with
what the FCC already has yeah and I'm
just trying to wonder why why is that
advantageous um like I said we're
neutral on this but we do believe the
current practice has been efficient
questions representative McGee yeah so I
heard what you said I heard your
testimony and it sounds like what you're
saying is it it it's not broken in any
way the Department's position is that
the process if if anybody wants to
participate in the lifeline program they
can apply through the process that
currently exists
and they would become members of the
lifeline program so there's not anything
inhibiting people doing it today that
would warrant us having to take it over
in order to improve it is that an
accurate correct yes um we have heard of
no uh obstacles for any any providers
than representative
Bernardi so would this transfer result
in an an expansion of the program in New
Hampshire um we don't we don't currently
we just don't believe it guarantees that
more uh providers will come online for
this um so I I can't I can't say if it
if it would be expanded or
not okay thank
you Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chair um going back
to your statement that there are no
obstacles for companies to apply now can
[Music]
you give us some perspective as to
perhaps why 45 other states felt a need
to enact legislation in order to allow
their states to get this done at the
state level I can't speak to uh why
other states made the decision no but I
can I can look into some some answers
for
you representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
uh for coming in again
I don't know if you have the answer to
this question but I'm looking at it from
the other point of view which is how
many New Hampshire citizens are
currently covered by a program such as
the lifeline program under the existing
carriers and do you do we have any
estimation of the need for this kind of
program in terms of people who are
lacking access to broadband Etc um I
don't have the answer to that currently
but I can look into that for
you any more questions representative
Thomas Doug Thomas thank you Mr chman
I'll I'll take this as my follow on
question um just out of
curiosity is there a cost for carriers
now to apply to the FCC to get their
capability and if so would that cost be
more expensive than having the state
handle it that I'm not entirely sure but
I will I'll find an answer for you today
okay seeing no more questions I'll thank
you thank you Miss stone for being here
and I don't see any more pink cards so
apparently we're we're done is there
anyone else who would like to testify on
House Bill
627 seeing none we'll close the public
hearing on House Bill
627 and
in N minutes nine minutes we will um
we will open a public hearing on House
Bill for
60 till then we're on
break
e
e e
so let's open a public hearing on House
Bill 4 60- FN relative to utility
investments in distributed energy
resources and call upon the bill sponsor
representative McGee to introduce
introduce this
legislation thank you Mr chairman and
colleagues on uh science technology and
energy uh I'm representative cat McGee
from Hillsboro 35
Hollis I come before you today in
support of HB 460 which is a simple bill
the bill seeks to further Define the
factors to be considered by the Public
Utilities Commission when being asked to
determine the public interest prior to
authorizing a UTI's recovery rate for
its portion of a distributed energy
investment as most are aware utilities
are able to invest uh in up to 6% of
their low demand in distributed energy
generation this was done this was um
decided upon in order to increase clean
energy Supply in the state and to
support fuel
diversity the statute in question is RSA
374 G5 to F and I've given you um a
print out of the section of 374 which is
the electric restructuring statute um
just so you can see it in context the
idea is that instead of uh letter F
simply saying the effect on comp on
competition within the Region's
electricity markets and the state
energy uh Services market so what it
what this bill seeks to do is rather
than leave that as a general statement
there to put some specificity to it so
when the Public Utilities Commission is
trying to determine whether something is
valuable um or the value of something
that they include the actual factors
that contribute to that value
so um it would read under Section F the
effect on competition with the Region's
electricity markets and the state Energy
Services Market including the extent to
which utility rates tariffs metering
data sharing Consolidated bills and load
estimation and settlement processes
enable customer generators and limited
producers under RSA 362a to be able to
realize credit for Value produced and
cost avoided comparable to those
benefits claimed in the electric
utilities proposal to support its
proposed investment that sounds like a
lot of words it's a mouthful but what it
does is it uh is Define the missing
Market factors in statute that should
receive consideration by the Public
Utilities Commission in the calculation
of utility rate filings for
reimbursement value it serves to provide
a level of specificity that is needed to
ensure the Pu standard of just and
reasonable for customers and make sure
that it's not in the eye of the beholder
but it can be justified and even
Quantified by including Market factors
when they apply to determine
reimbursement rates importantly this
bill incorporates the need to properly
value customer generators and limited
producers for their role in avoided
costs for the utilities and customers
these are contributing factors they are
not represented in the statute today and
they should be listed in the statute so
that's the reason for the bill my last
point I'll I'll give you before I open
up for questions is you may have noticed
like many of the bills that we have this
year um this bill has a fiscal note um I
looked into why um specifying seven
additional Market factors in statutory
language would result in a fiscal note
because it's a very short Bill and I
called the office of legislative
Services they referred me to the
legislative budget office I'm sorry the
uh
LBA um legislative budget
assistant um and Mr Shay told me that
Ben Martin McDon of the Pu had responded
on behalf of head commissioner Dan
goldner and that uh commissioner goldner
had said the
Pu would need to open an adjudicative
proceeding and hire staff Andor
consultants if the bill passed into law
um in last week's
testimony Mr spidel who's an attorney at
the Public Utilities Commission uh
mentioned that when they have questions
for which they no longer have staff
expertise uh they rely on subject matter
experts from various stakeholders within
the state they have access to them all
they come into the Pu all the time in
this in that case it was the New
Hampshire co-op that had provided
expertise when they had a question um
but they also have access to the
utilities and people from Community
power and all of them have sign
significant expertise they can and would
be willing to informally provide to
assist the state agencies in
understanding the complexity of any of
these issues um adding this language to
statute would not require an
adjudicative proceeding unless our puuc
is unfamiliar with utility rates tariffs
metering data sharing Consolidated bills
load estimation and settlement and the
importance of price signals for Value
produced and costs avoided
these are the nuts and bolts of the work
the Public Utilities Commission is
employed as our regul regulatory body to
to
undertake so if this knowledge does not
exist in our current Energy Regulatory
agency that's more a commentary on
decisions we've made in government
reforms there but this expertise did
exist in the Public Utilities Commission
when I first came to conquer but it that
should not stop us from voting
unanimously to Divine to to Define that
these factors belong in the statute in
order to help preserve competition in
the electricity Market which is really
the point of the bill so with that um
and I did give you all a handout and it
it's just um the section of 374 where
this would be
inserted so I hope I hope uh my
explanation is clear in
that currently there are some
questions um at PU hearings about what
should be in consideration for when
these projects are being invested in and
if we can clarify that information as a
legislature for them in the statutory
language then it's no longer a question
if all of these apply or only some of
them apply the the fact is the list
should be more comprehensive rather than
less and there can always be individual
discussions based on the adjudicative
proceeding that's in front of the Public
Utilities Commission
but most of these are very standard
standardized um terms in terms of energy
energy valuation the value stack if you
will and um they are customarily being
used by other Public Utilities
commissions all over the region and all
over the United States so um they're not
uh they shouldn't be presenting a real
stumbling block uh for our
regulators and that's it
well thank you representative McGee
thank you so did I understand you to say
that adding six
new
um seven I think I said six or seven
whatever new areas for invest
investigation uh would not
increase to some degree the the work
that the public Utilities Commission
must
do
[Music]
to to rule on the effective
competition uh within within these
Services Mar I did not discuss
investigations because the
investigations are not
um the investigations are being provided
by the utilities right that the data
would be provided on all of these inputs
these would be the things that the
Public Utilities Commission would want
to consider and could consider and we as
a legislative body are simply taking
those definitions and putting them into
statute so that there is now uh a list
of the items that have
value that should be considered it's not
telling them they have to consider them
it's telling them this is the list you
should be looking at tariffs you should
be looking at data sharing Consolidated
billing load estimation these are the
components
that are not currently articulated in
the restructuring statute that should be
considered for for the valuation going
back to the
utilities
um and I guess the whole point of it is
to get to an accurate reimbursement to
the utilities for the benefit of the
projects that they're bringing on and
there are other contributors often times
in those right there's the people who
are actually doing the generation that
they're supporting so right now there
isn't a real clear path for them to be
able to say how does this get parsed and
how much does the utility get reimbursed
for this how much you know how much of
this is to their benefit and how much of
it belongs to the generation asset or
the or the uh you know the small
producers that are actually um helping
to put it together so these are the
components that would have to be under
consideration and
you asked about investigation I there's
nothing in here about investigation
because generally how the Public
Utilities Commission works is if the
utilities want to be reimbursed for
something and they're bringing a project
to them they will give them whatever it
is they're required to give them if this
isn't in language then these items will
not be given to them if these items are
in language then I'm sure that when they
come to find out what that reimbursement
is going to be the rate reimbursement
they're going to bring this information
to the Public Utilities Commission it
would not be the responsibility of the
Public Utilities Commission to be an
expert on these things or to provide
their own
information so my followup would be then
who tries
to determine how to realize credit for
Value produced and cost
avoided well if it's an adjudicative
proceeding and it and it would be
because these are
utility uh investments in in distribut
energy so it would be a a rate case
where the utility is seeking to gain
reimbursement and so they would they
would be the they would be making the
case
right for what for what they're
due but now the Public Utilities
Commission would be able to ask on these
specifics to get further information to
make sure that they actually uh UE those
things so this information would use be
used to justify the ities investment in
a Dr resource yep and these are these
are known components they're just not
currently in the in the uh electric
restructuring statutory language okay
and that so that's all we're trying to
do is add it and when I saw the fiscal
note like you have to hire people in
order to read the you know it it it
really is just asking us to say we know
that these things exist and that they
affect the valuation utility rates
matter tariffs matter how met ings being
done data all these pieces are
components so all we're saying is this
language should be included there so
that it can be uh discussed at a
detailed level at the Public Utilities
Commission representative Harrington has
a question yeah thank you um so I'm
trying to get this straight it sounds
like what you're saying is that there's
no analysis required by the Pu on this
so they're going to be giving they're
going to be giving a figure that
represents utility rates another figure
that represents tariff another figure
that represents metering another figure
that represents data sharing so forth
and so on and they're going to be a
whole stack of these things and they're
going to say okay they all add up to
something we don't have to analyze them
we just we we whatever the utility gives
us we're accepting and that's how we're
going to determine this process I don't
think you you asking the the Pu to
Simply say his you his tariffs there's a
number his metering data there's a
number and they they will just say well
whatever you tell us that's what we're
accepting as fact thank you for the
question former public utilities
commissioner uh Michael Harrington um no
I don't think that's how it works I mean
generally adjudicative proceedings have
stakeholders and interveners and it's
not just the utilities that'll be
providing the information or answering
the questions so there'll be a number of
um interested parties I'm sure that
would be available so that there
wouldn't have to be a lot of discussion
about what utility rate applies or what
tariff applies or what net me metering
uh cost applies I think those things can
be figured out pretty easily um and also
I think for a long time we've been
seeing bills and hearing that there is a
discrepancy in statutory law that allows
for the load estimation and settlement
process that's been kind of a sticking
point for a while it's right there's
value there um we're not um
acknowledging it and not properly uh
costing for it so I think what you do is
you broaden the conversation for the
folks who are engaged on any given
docket at the Public Utilities
Commission to have the conversations at
the level that they need to for whatever
the particular project is if it doesn't
apply then it doesn't apply follow up
followup well I I'm still trying to get
this straight then you're saying that
there's multiple people coming in so the
utility may come in and say uh we
consider uh you this the Tariff to be
this and metering to be that and
somebody else can come in and say no no
no we disagree with that we're the uh I
don't know the consumer Advocate or
somebody so then it's up to the Pu is's
going to have to analyze this this these
numbers that are given there and I don't
know where they're going to get the
staff to do that I guess they defer to
the Department of energy to do some
investigation on that filing and then
make a determination is yeah we agree
that the metering number that was
provided by the utility is correct or no
we think it's too high or too low I mean
they're just not going to accept this on
face value especially when you talk
about an adjudicative process anybody
can challenge them and if you're
challenging them then the puc has to
have some ability to go somewhere and
say we need this independently checked
out by someone who doesn't have a bias
one way or the other I agree with you I
I was against their staff being cut when
their staff was cut but uh you know we
have to move forward from the present
reality um so I guess what I'm saying is
that the adjudicative proceeding that
I've witnessed um always have
information coming from both sides that
has to be analyzed um and the Staffing
considerations are something we need to
hear from the Public Utilities
Commission on we're not responsible for
figuring out those you know we were told
when the department of energy was
created and the dep the Public Utilities
Commission jobs all went over to doe
that they would be providing some
support there so I can't answer the
question about what level of expertise
they have but they are the regulatory
body that is in charge of this aspect of
our law so um I
think I think that the fact that there
may be issues with uh sufficient
expertise among the Public Utilities
Commission as as it is currently
constituted is a separate issue from
whether or not this body should
unanimously pass this bill saying that
these are the things that should be
considered when a utility is looking for
reimbursement in order to make sure that
the price that they are being given is
just and
reasonable um as as a statute
requires so I I don't know how else to
say it I just
think if this is confusing to people I I
don't know who else within our
government can figure out how to
understand these because they are the
people that are responsible for this so
it's so section F which is the section
we're under discussion here is part of
section two yep and section two is all
about
authorizing the utilities recovery of
Investments yes correct
yep so section F wants part of that
authorization to recover Investments to
investigate the effect on
competition that's what section f is all
about correct
yep
so that being the
case it's not
clear
what some of these factors here rates
tariffs metering data sharing have to do
with with competition in the Region's
electricity markets can you elaborate on
what those I think effects might be well
I think section
two is not just utility investment
recovery but utility investment recovery
for distributed energy resources so what
comes into play is the competitors that
are providing the generation and how we
allocate which portions of the value of
the project that are being done go to
which of the participants in creating
the energy and making it available so
it's a competitive market and uh this is
this section section two is only about
the utilities ability to recover what
they should rightfully recover for
investing in distributed energy in a
particular project and so the argument
goes that the section that says the
effect on
competition um is the appropriate place
to put in
including these factors uh that should
be considered in order to come to a a
correct valuation that are currently not
in the mix and I there's probably people
who can articulate it better than I can
because it's their business it's not my
business this is my my understanding of
um why we're putting it where we're
putting it and what it will uh what it
will assist with because you'll note
that in the bolded language in the bill
which is a very you know one paragraph
bill um It also says uh and load
estimation and settlement processes um
enable customer generators and limited
producers under RSA 362a to be able to
realize credit for Value produced and
costs avoided okay though it is getting
complicated I mean everything is getting
complicated but if you want to have a
free market you have to first valuate
the pieces
appropriately and I think that's what
this um that's what this bill is
attempting to do is trying to pull into
the conversation the pieces that
actually exist already but that may not
be under
consideration representative Kaplan has
a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you represent McGee for bringing this
forward and I think you've done an
admirable job trying to explain the
different the different items here U
because it is complicated but I I don't
want us to lose a view of the forest for
the trees I think there's a lot of trees
here uh and I agree that the state and
the Regulatory Commission ought to have
the bandwidth to deal with these trees
if they're important to the to the
underlying statute which is intended to
bring on more uh dist yeah I do so how
how does this the underlying statute is
intended to bring on more distributed
energy correct and also at the same time
Preserve erve uh a competitive
Marketplace that's that's the section
we're talking about so how how does this
bill bring on or a guarantee that as it
you know which is our our our under our
overall overarching interest is to bring
on more distributed generation correct
so how does this bill do that and how
does it preserve a Marketplace yeah I
don't I don't think it does I think it's
more aimed at um it's more aimed at
making sure that on the competitive
market side that the valuation that is
provided to these projects is
distributed properly and understood
properly and it's it's
almost uh it's an attempt
to require more sophistication in the
conversation around um you know how this
new market is going to work together all
right so it's going to it's going to put
into
statute uh
uh factors or
um components that might not fully be
being considered but that we would like
them to be considered in order to
support the competitive market and so I
don't think it increases anything I
think the utilities are still going to
be um doing what they're doing in terms
of their investments in in distributed
energy resources um up to that 6%
requirement of their load you know up to
what they can invest in um so uh I I
don't think it increases anything you'd
have to increase the 6% if you wanted to
actually say they could do more um so
this bill doesn't get at what the
utilities are doing in this vein it just
says that under the electric utility
investment in distributed energy
resources section of
Statute uh under
authorization that uh the
effects on competition piece will have
additional uh clarification in terms of
what should be
considered representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um and thank you
representative are these Common Sense
factors currently be being considered
when looking at the effect on
competition and even if they are
wouldn't standardizing and identifying
these factors make things more efficient
fair and overall a more balanced
consideration thank you for the question
yeah I mean that's that's kind of the
nail on the head not not the first part
of the question but the second half is
that if you standardize around language
of what's expected then every case would
be uniform in terms of How It's viewed
and as I mentioned before not every
component here would be relevant in
every case and so it would be on a
case-by casee basis but at least the
parties would be able to say does it
relate does it not relate so there would
be um you know something in statute to
hold on to to be able to have the
conversation about whether something is
being left out and I don't think it's
overly burdensome to the Public
Utilities Commission either because this
is really as I said in my testimony it's
the nuts and bolts of what they're doing
it's the market that's different um and
that has to be um accommodated in terms
of how we view the value I I know when
uh it's going going back a bit but when
Lee oxam was here she used to bring in
charts and everything about the value
stack and she would talk about um how
other states view the value stack of uh
renewable energy in terms of what it
provides to the system it isn't steady
state but it does provide reliability
um because it augments and it helps with
Peak and you know it does a whole bunch
of things so it's complicated to look at
all the issues and I guess what this
bill is trying to do is say the Public
Utilities Commission is is where we want
them to look at these issues and um and
if they need something if they really
need something I'm sure they're going to
come testify they can let us know what
that is but the fact
is this isn't going to go away way these
components
are are there thank you yeah we didn't
make them
up representative Bernardi has a
question you Mr chair
so I I've been looking at the the the
core statute here which F subsection f
is a part of and I I look at G and H in
particular and I say you you're asking
there that the costs and benefits uh in
the competitive market are to all be
addressed so in my mind all the things
that you listed are embodied in g& h
already in assessing competition so I
I'm I'm not understanding why we need
this language can you help me understand
why G and H don't work why they don't
work for what you're trying to get done
um well I mean I think they're separate
and distinct I think f is about the
effects of on the competition and that's
where the items um that affect the
valuation here are in f um all of these
are distinct right A through I they're
all different aspects um of number two
of of how to um figure out the recovery
um on distributed energy resource
investment so I I
don't I don't see g& as actually being
the same I mean they're they're talking
about the expected value and economic
benefits of the investment to the
utilities rate payers is distinct and
the cost and benefits to the utilities
customers is distinct so um the place
where this language goes is appropriate
I mean was is appropriately the effect
on uh competition within the Region's
electricity markets and the state's
Energy Services market so it's it's
separate in my mind so I I don't I don't
have any other answer for you I don't
see them as being overlapping I I see
them as different follow follow up yes
so when when you're looking at
competition you've identified those
seven factors when you're looking in g&
you're looking at uh the cost and the
benefits to both the utility and to the
rate payers so when you're looking at
the to benefits to the rate payers the
kinds of things that you're identifying
in your seven factors are those factors
so if if you're doing that assessment
you've covered the base so are you
suggesting that we take those factors
and put that specificity in G versus F
I'm suggesting you don't need it at
all well f is the effect on competitive
markets right so that's another
consideration that they have
so thank you all right let's see if we
can hear from some other folks on this U
legislation I know there's quite a few
folks here have signed up to give us
their perspective we might learn um more
from them so let's call on next Megan
Stone and Matthew Young from the New
Hampshire Department of energy
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Matt Young and I'm an attorney with the
New Hampshire Department of
energy um the department is uh neutral
on this legislation currently um I think
similar to the language that was in the
fiscal note um coming into today we were
a bit unclear on the intent and the
effect of the bill um I will after uh
hearing representative McGee test Tony
um I think I could offer a few points um
that might help some some
context uh first which I think was
discussed I just wanted to kind of
emphasize is that this bill uh
specifically deals with the uh 374 G
projects I'll call them um since my time
at the department I'm only aware of two
such projects that have come before the
Public Utilities Commission definitely
one I think there's one other um and
then
I would also note that I believe Mr
chairman you mentioned what we're
calling I think the seven areas um or
factors uh that are included in this
bill and several of those factors are
currently um being considered by the
Public Utilities Commission Now in
current dockets um I wouldn't say that
all of them are being considered but
several of them are being considered in
fact um the extent to which the utility
does um provide that information is is
is being considered and with that I'd be
happy to answer some
questions okay any questions for the
Department representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um and thank you for
being here um you just said that several
of those factors are currently being
considered are but not all of them but
are there some decisions that are made
that are not including some of these
factors
and could that could that lead
to not enough information on a
decision so the the um dockets that I
was speaking of aren't 374 G projects so
it's a little different context um but
the extent to which the utilities are
providing um for an example I think data
sharing um related to Consolidated
billing things like that are being
considered does that answer your
question
follow up followup followup
um so I think what I'm trying to say is
if there if they're you're saying not
all of these factors are being
considered if they're if they're
considering some of these factors in one
case some of the different perhaps
different factors in another case how is
that a balanced
consideration I'm not sure I fully
understand the question to be able to PR
answer to that that's okay thank
you okay any additional questions
representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair and uh thank
you for being here uh the question I
have is would uh does it seem like it it
would these be considered uh just an
encouragement as far as uh F here uh to
uh be a little bit more specific to uh
encourage due diligence on this matter
so that these items are enumerated for
the Public's
confidence I would say it definitely
provides more specificity than is
currently included thank you thank you
Mr chair okay thank
you representative Harrington has a
question yeah thank you chairman and
think we taking my question I'm just
trying to get this straight As who's
going to do what is it the Department's
position that if this was was passed
into law that determining all of these
new factors now would be done by them
and submitted to the Pu or is it going
to be just submitted to the Pu by the
utilities and no one in the department
of uh energy is going to look at it uh
how how do you Vision that working so um
I would Envision similar to um one of
the other dockets that considered one of
these projects uh it is the I would say
it's the utilities burden to meet
whatever statutory requirements are out
there um then the department does its
review provides a recommendation um for
the
commission followup followup so you
would Envision then that the the utility
submitt would go to the doe for review
and then a recommendation back to the
commission so there would be people
involved in doing this at the department
of energy so I'm sorry they would file a
petition at the Public Utilities
Commission to which the department would
be a party to that proceeding okay all
right thank you
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um the previous speaker talked
about these and and he identified them
as new factors so are these new factors
or are they factors that are currently
being um looked at by the
puc and if they are current factors then
what is wrong with identifying
them I would defer that question to the
commission I don't know that their order
on the on the recent proceeding was was
that
specific okay seeing no further
questions I want to thank the two of you
for testifying here today and I'd like
to call on Henry hearnen from this
community power Coalition of New
Hampshire to give us his perspective on
this
legislation good afternoon Henry nice to
see you again good afternoon Mr chairman
nice to see you as well
Mr chairman um members of the committee
uh my name is Henry hearen I am the
director of member services with
Community power Coalition of New
Hampshire uh we are a not for-profit
power agency and supplier governed by
local communities here in the state um
and operated by industry experts we uh
part of what we do is expand competitive
energy choices available to homes and
businesses and over the past couple of
years since this Market has taken off in
the state um we have supported home uh
homes and businesses to save more than
$20 million on their electric bills uh
and we think there's a lot more value to
be had with uh opportunities to uh
expand and competitive opportunities in
the energy space
um uh I'm here to uh testify on behalf
of cbcn in support of House Bill 460
because it is a an important tool in
helping to level the playing field
between utility companies and uh the
competitive market in providing
cost-saving Energy Solutions to
customers so distributed energy
resources when they are cost-effective
um in the form of you know local
renewable energy generators energy
storage
or other uh demand management tools can
reduce wholesale power costs uh costs
associated with the iso New England and
costs associated with our Interstate
transmission infrastructure by just
producing power a little closer to home
and not having to rely on those large
outof State uh infrastructures um and
the associated
costs part of the purpose of this uh
legislation um is uh to address a
challenge where currently State
regulation is inadvertently
potentially granting utility companies a
monopoly on the development of these
local power resources and undermining
the ability of customers to have choice
and for the comp competitive market to
innovate and provide some of those
solutions that can save costs for
customers um there's some examples and
perhaps I'll talk about at least one of
them but uh utilities are proposing and
developing some distributed energy
projects one good example i' I've passed
around material from uni Till's proposal
uh developing a five megawatt solar
tracker tracker meaning it follows the
sun um in Kingston New Hampshire now
this is a good project supportive of
this project it's uh kudos to Unitil for
sort of innovating and saying hey we can
save customers money if we have a local
generator and if we look at all of the
ways that can produce value for
customers
um and what that does is it lowers the
Uni's costs from wholesale power
purchases from the transmission system
uh and line losses and some other values
we feel that this legislation is
important in enabling the same
justifications that allow the Monopoly
utility to create those projects those
same justifications should be available
on a competitive market basis to sort of
just expand choice and have the
competition create um ways to drive down
cost for customers um so we would
propose that this um bill should be
voted ought to pass uh to to bolster
that market and I just want to respond
to a couple of the the items that have
been disc discussed I think a key
feature was identified uh that this is
the section relative to the effect on
competition and it may I think perhaps
there a little bit confusion the intent
is not to have more regulation the
intent is to have less regulation to
allow unregulated entities to uh have a
Level Playing Field on some of the rules
that the utilities have and also what
was discussed is sort of what do these
factors have to do with competition and
I'll just maybe try to clarify that
question
um so tariffs meters load estimation
these are the factors what do they have
to do with competition so what Unitil
has said is let's look at a tariff the
transmission tariff uh that sends a
price signal it says that the monthly
peak hour drives the transmission cost
does my uh solar project produce power
during that monthly Peak now it's
lowering my monthly Peak transmission
cost so that's the Tariff and perhaps
the metering component do we have a
meter that measures that solar raise
reduction to the transmission tariff
then we could look at load estimation
load estimation has to do with how much
power do we estimate We Buy in ISO New
England well if we have a transmission
tariff and we have a solar array and
we're metering its production during the
monthly transmission Peak we can now
estimate a reduction in our load that we
buy from ISO New England these are the
rules that unisil has used to justify
that investment and they're good and
they show look now we're paying less for
power because we got a local project in
ISO and transmission costs are going
down what this legislation is suggesting
is that those factors that are
justifying Monopoly utility Investments
shouldn't be restricted to the Monopoly
utility only inadvertently we have a
situation where a competitive developer
or competitive supplier are unable to
make that same cost-effective investment
and be paid for the lowering of the
transmission tariff the the reduction to
their estimated wholesale load um that's
why those factors are being listed and
that's why we feel this legislation is
necessary to expand sort of a
marketplace where customers can choose
some of those options um so I'll be
happy to answer any questions and
perhaps speak more to the the specifics
of the factors uh and I appreciate the
committee's
time thank you excellent testimony so do
you think that the additions to this
legislation as outlined in this bill
will enable utilities when they're
trying to recover their cost for invest
investing in De distributed energy
resources to do something like what
Unitil did in uh
estimating the effect
on their own rates tariffs Etc and so
you think that putting this in statute
here will be beneficial to limited
electrical producers under RSA uh 362a
and and other customer generators is
that is that the goal here yes the goal
is perhaps maybe not comprehensively but
in a stepwise fashion getting closer
to good utilities are doing these
projects we can calculate then see that
they're saving power or saving money we
want to allow them on a limited basis
and the what we've learned here and what
we've seen about how the load estimation
of the tariffs and and these are being
considered um to lower costs those fact
factors we want to consider to make them
available to the competitive market as
well so the utility can't discriminate
and say we can reduce our load
estimation and we can save cost but you
the competitive supplier cannot your
load estimation remains unchanged you
are not able to lower your own costs
those would be socialized and said
there's a current problem where load
estimation reductions for this for the
non-utility projects under this section
um they're socialized to all customers
we as a supplier um we would like to
have power from a local project that
reduces how much power we have to buy in
the iso New England and then not have to
double pay for it not have
to this would help to enable us to
provide more cost savings by having the
same
justifications follow-up question would
be do do any of the types
of
uh materials that would be necessary to
back up these these estimates of
competition um Market competition are
any of
those like proprietary data that the
utilities would be reluctant to divulge
and so with imposing this kind of
requirement on them discourage them from
doing these de
projects not to my knowledge I don't
believe so I don't believe that it would
be proprietary um
right and really you know in the Unitil
example they've sort of done the good
work of showing the value um and then
this would just provide that
clarification to the commission and in
future projects saying yes we approve
you Unitil to do this project and allow
apply the same load reduction and tariff
methodology to a competitive market
actor so they can go and make their own
private investment and we don't have to
sort of rate base all the investments in
distributed energy we can just allow
private investment to do that without
having the sort of regulated rate
return other questions representative
Harrington yeah thank you for taking my
question
um so I'm a little confused here it
we're talking about the electric utility
May seek rate recovery for a portion of
its investments in distributed energy
but then you're talking about someone
that's who's investing in distributed
energy that's not a public utility
so as part of the filing for the public
utility they're supposed to say because
we're doing this distributed generation
energy project it has some effect on
making someone else's distributed energy
project cheaper and they the utility was
going to calculate that and then give it
to whoever this somebody else is and
then they'll get paid more or get credit
I'm just I don't understand how this is
working what if the utility doesn't file
anything yeah I I think that's a good
question um I think I think the
intention is um the the way the statute
is already outlined there is a series of
factors that the Pu must consider ABCD
one of those factors is what does the
effect on competition of the utility
investment right now the effect on
competition is utilities have a certain
set of rules on load estimation that
they can use but the marketplace doesn't
have a fair access to that same set of
rules so we we feel that a Level Playing
Field where the rule utilities are able
to use to justify their investment
shouldn't be only available to the
utility and in the public utility
commission's consideration of approving
that project again I'm not saying I
don't think utilities should be able to
do some of these costeffective projects
but in the commission's consideration of
that those same justifications would now
be opened up and made available to The
Limited producers or the competitive
actors
followup follow up yeah I I understand
you want to have the same set of rules
for everybody but I'm trying to get more
practice IC on how this would work you
have the utility filing a putting a rate
case in for their distributed energy
resource and they want to get their
their money back and whatever and so
forth so on and somehow in the process
of that filing they're going to
calculate how much credit should be
realized for in value produced and cost
avoided for comparable to those benefits
for who some unnamed uh distributed
generator or is they have to do this
monthly or is this done once a year what
if they don't invest in any distributed
generation then and how is that credit
going to get to the private distributed
uh energy um
producer I don't know if I have an exact
answer to that question I think it's a
good question and I think again the
intent is you know looking at the rates
tariffs metering data these are all the
things Unitil has done the homework and
they've looked at those things and shown
look our load settlement has gone down
because we've got local power and then
it says um
you know how does this enable customer
generators and limited producers under
the law uh to be able to realize credit
for Value produced and costs avoided
comparable to those benefits claimed in
the electric utilities proposal so this
is again it's just saying utility you
can still do your project you just
cannot block a competitive market actor
from doing a similar project and
similarly using load estimation or uh
tariffs or metering to
to be compensated the same way you're
compensating yourself okay follow
up one more that's it okay that'll be it
I I understand the the basic you kind of
come with the principle the same rule
should apply to everybody if the utility
puts in a two megawatt generation and
they get so much credit for transmission
savings or whatever then someone else
doing that should get it I'm trying to
figure out the process because this is a
filing that the utility makes so the
utility is putting in a two gen two
megawatt solar panel some Farm someplace
they come up with and they come up with
specific savings for that two two
megawatts in that location and then
somehow someone else is going to put up
a one megawatt solar thing 150 miles
away right and they're going to say well
whatever they claimed in savings over
there we're getting over here and of
course there's a difference here because
the utility has to provide load so that
two megawatts turns off because it's
cloudy they go get the power from
someplace else right the private One
megawatt turns off because it's cloudy
they just don't run they get no penalty
well so that would be under net metering
but not under a limited producer or sort
of a market construct I would agree with
you and and again that's why if you
don't produce during the transmission
Peak we shouldn't pay you for saving
transmission costs but if you produce
during that then we would pay you and I
think again this is there might be a
larger sort of look at how can we ensure
you know the a correct retail Market in
the state I think this is at least
saying to the Public Utility Commission
when you're approving these projects ask
the question
are is the market able to play by the
same rules that the utility is able to
play by and if it's not then can we sort
of try to enable that further so there's
more
competition representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Hearn uh for coming in
so these seven
factors are they being appli I got a
couple questions but are they being
applied now in the regular
utility rate case under this statute and
if they're not is your intent to make
the investment in distributed generation
easier for utilities as well as for the
competitive suppliers
or uh they are being so in the Unitil
example which I'll return to um they are
being applied Unitil is essentially
saying look um we have this much less
wholesale energy cost this much less
wholesale capacity cost this much less
transmission line loss ancillary
Services all the fees that are part of
the iso system um similarly there's you
know there are State studies of what is
the value of a local load reducer or
distributed energy resource and they
look at all those same the cost stack
the value stack that we've discussed um
so I I don't know that we're trying to
say we want more or less utility
Investments as opposed to the bill was
is just clarifying already the p is
directed to look at the effect on
competition we know the effect on
competition is important to the state in
existing law these seven factors they're
the nuts and bolts of the how does it
affect competition and can certain
entities or utilities or monopolies use
these factors one way what without
letting Market actors do the same and we
we feel that if Market actors were able
to do the same we'd have a much more
efficient deployment of those resources
as opposed to having the Pu adjudicate
each one for two years you could just
say hey did you produce during the
transmission Peak did it lower your load
settlement we're going to do the load
settlement math correctly
now okay representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman so just
following on to what you just said um
would it be correct to characterize this
as as saying that by having this
information explicitly
included that it creates a more
efficient market
we I I would suggest it would be a step
in that direction yes I think it would
it again it's it it puts to the
consideration what are the factors that
are being used to justify this and is
there is it kind of done on a
discriminatory basis or is it on an open
access basis so I think that would be a
step towards creating a more efficient
market there's perhaps other the our
retail Market in the state there perhaps
a number of things that would be needed
to make a truly competitive and when I
say retail market we've we've succeeded
at a wholesale level we have the iso New
England there's real-time price signals
it's based on supply and demand it's a
true marketplace where generators are
competing at a retail level we don't
have the price
signals uh and we don't have some of
these other factors like the load
estimation and the Open Access so there
is perhaps a broader conversation about
how do we truly establish Market
competition in a New Hampshire level at
a retail level uh that can alleviate
some of the costs of the iso I think
this is a step in that direction but not
a comprehensive
solution okay seeing no other questions
I want to thank you that's excellent
testimony as usual from the CPC and so
next we'll hear the perspective of
eversource as Michael Lata will give us
the utilities perspective on this
proposed
legislation good afternoon
thank you very much uh for the record
Michael Lata representing eversource uh
energy appreciate the opportunity to
testify before you today um a lot of
questions that the committee has had and
I think perhaps part of the source of
that is how the bill is is structured um
as has been discussed the bill would add
several up just for the record again uh
ever source is opposed to the bill uh
that is has as it has been introduced
um the bill would add several new
factors and it's important to state that
those are new factors they are not a uh
something that is currently under
consideration when the Public Utilities
Commission is reviewing utility
Investments as part of 374 G um and
these are the factors that the
commission does take into account and
weigh when determining if those specific
projects that a utility is proposing are
in the public interest and I think it's
really really important to focus on the
fact that the commission is reviewing
the costs the benefits the manner in
which a utility went about con proposing
to construct these projects this is not
um done on a Statewide basis it is very
Project Specific it's location specific
uh it is not tied uh to a a broader
kind of policy issue um we believe that
the current factors are in fact clear
and well understood uh and they also
make sense when determining whether a
specific project is in the public
interest if you review the statute there
are items such as uh whether the project
would impact the safety reliability of
the grid the costs the benefits the
environmental impacts and the addition
of these new factors uh we believe are
are unclear and do not appear to be
consistent with the evaluation of a
specific project and the cost and
benefits of that project instead the new
factors appear to shift the entire
conversation at the Public Utilities
Commission instead of being a review of
the project is now would be based on
whether or not an unregulated third
party has a some form of compensation
for their
competitive uh distributed energy
resources
which quite frankly if you look at 374 G
it is very clear and very specific and
there are very clear limitations on the
types of projects that utilities are
allowed to construct third parties don't
have to uh nor should they have any of
those limitations applied to them uh so
you're taking the review and cost
benefit and public interest finding of a
specific project and shifting that
conversation to should unregulated
third-party competitive uh projects have
some form of distrib some form of
compensation that would ultimately be
provided for uh by customers uh we don't
believe that that's helpful we don't
believe that that's in keeping with the
intent of 374 G and I would also point
out that as was discussed 374 G has only
been used successfully once in the state
of New Hampshire and candidly it is
disappointing to see
the legislature contemplating after the
one successful project stepping in and
changing the rules of the game for
utilities uh this would have a chilling
effect on utility investment and
candidly with this new language it's
unclear whether we would even be able to
uh continue to provide or or look for
Investments uh similar to the Unitil
Kingston project um there were a number
of statements made by uh the gentleman
uh Mr hearnen from Community power I I
think a number of them are factually
incorrect uh stating that utilities are
blocking investment stating that
utilities have a monopoly on distributed
energy resources uh simply put uh we
fundamentally disagree with those
normally I wouldn't comment on another
uh you know testifiers
uh uh Speech uh but those were far
beyond the pale and uh quite frankly we
feel the need to say on the record that
that is uh certainly our belief that
those are factually incorrect statements
and I'd be happy to take any uh
questions that the committee may
have well thank you for your uh candid
testimony I do have a question it would
appear that the intent of this
legislation is to codify and
statute some Concepts that
are difficult to
prove Concepts like avoided load avoided
transmission and distribution cost
avoided line
losses when you apply those to
distributed energy resources because
they're intermittent
resources isn't it difficult to figure
out exactly if they're if they even
exist much less what how to quantify
them I I I think there there seems to be
a fundamental disconnect
um
between and again I I don't work at
Unitil as the committee knows I I really
can't speak to uh their Kingston filing
however there does seem to be a
disconnect between the interpretation by
uh one Community power organization of
the utilities positioning and what
they're seeking so
um I'll try to speak in more general
terms because I I you know
Unitil can speak about their project but
essentially when they were uh when a
utility is making the filing with the
Public Utilities Commission they're
showing that the benefits of the project
outweigh the costs so how much do it
cost to build and the utilities rate of
return which is
regulated um and what are the benefits
and there are a number of different
benefits that utilities could could show
uh compliance with the renewable
portfolio standard for example that
these are essentially wreck generating
if there are uh you know exports at the
time of coincident Peak as has been
discussed there can be uh transmission
benefits associated with that or um
capacity benefits those are cost savings
so those are are estimated exports that
you model out May save customers money
that is very very different than saying
and this is not has not been the
position of the utilities that they
should be compensated on those estimated
levels and so it's very different to say
all customers will receive a benefit
from this because we are estimating
certain savings versus write me a check
for that those are two very different
things and if you cons if you walk
through and I think representative
Harrington was trying to to go there how
would that happen how what's the
mechanics of providing that benefit back
so you're saying that a third-party
unregulated generator has exported at
the same time as the coincident
transmission Peak and so had that export
not occurred the transmission Peak would
be higher so the utility then has to
artificially increase their transmission
costs to create a revenue stream to
provide back to that generator so in
effect you're increasing costs to all
customers in order to write a check to
an unregulated third party again the
mechanics of it get kind of messy and
slippery very quickly and all that to
say we don't believe any of that should
be part of a UT part of the public
utilities commission's review of whether
the costs and the benefits of a very
specific utility investment
are are in the public
interest thank you thank you
representative Harrington has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question getting back to what
we we kind of just refer to there I'm
still trying to figure how this would
work because it appears that the let's
say eversource decides they're going to
put in a 3 megawatt uh solar panel in uh
I don't know in Portsmouth uh uh new
hampsh
now they put it in and they estimate
that there going to it's going to save
this and it's going to you're going to
get benefits because you can get wrecks
from it and it's going to Peak shave or
whatever you come up with some type of
an estimate of of the cost savings and
put it against the cost benefit and and
if it comes out positive then you'll
build it and hopefully the commission
would approve it so then you have those
numbers but now somebody else decides
two months later they want to build a
let's say the same thing a 2 megawatt
solar project but they want to build it
in coldbrook and there's a whole
different uh transmission system
distribution's different the location's
different so under this I guess they
would just say well whatever they saved
in Portsmouth we want credit for here
does that is that kind of the logic of
this that's that's what I'm reading
it I don't know if that is the intent I
think it's a fair question that you're
asking I I would note that um what I
believe you heard from the Department of
energy is many of these Concepts around
load settlement Consolidated billing the
data sharing that goes on between the
utilities and um thirdparty aggregations
are currently being discussed as part of
active adjudications at the Public
Utilities Commission and I know that
there are because they're available
several other bills that will come
before you today on those same topics so
I I don't know if it's trying to force a
resolution in those active adjudication
I I
I it confuses us as well okay follow up
follow up only one this time uh so the
way I read this as well then is if a
period goes by two three four years and
the utility doesn't opt to do one of
these distributed energy projects it's
up to them they they're not being forced
to do it so then somebody else wants to
put in a third party one they're going
to look and say we want to save this
well there's no analysis has been done
how am I going to get my credit I mean
is that the open question here if
there's none performed by the utility
then there's no basis for determining
the credit so how do you assign someone
credit for a third party I I I think
that's a fair question all right thank
you rhetorical but fair representative U
Wendy Thomas thank you Mr chair and
actually this may be a point of order um
um I don't recall um in last term or
this term one respected testifier
questioning another well-respected
testifier integrity and
honesty um could we please invite the
original testifier back to clarify and
defend their
statements well I'm going to have to
disagree with you that Mr Lata somehow
imputed the
U the honesty of Mr Heen I think what he
was criticizing was or disagreeing with
was Mr hen's fact acts and ideas so I
don't see it's necessary to allow Mr
Hern to come back and defend himself I
know he can defend himself very ably uh
but Mr Lata is entitled to disagree with
what Mr hearnen
presented any other questions
representative Kaplan thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr Lata um I'll go back to
my original point in a previous question
which is the underlying statute
identifies distributed generation
resources as a as a priority for our
state in terms of utility Investments
and we want to we want to activate that
by this statute um and we also know that
there's been a very slow uptake of this
opportunity on the part of the
utilities so and you're also saying that
these seven factors have nothing to do
with your business model and won't help
at all so what are the factors that we
ought to be looking at in order to
incentivize the utilities to take up
more investment and distributed
generation if these aren't the
ones so I think it's fair to say that
there has been
um limited execution of this portion of
the statute by the utilities there had
been previous orders and positions by
previous Public Utilities commissions
that sort of cast uh at least forever
Source concern that invest ments using
this uh this portion of the statute
would not be well looked upon by the
Public Utilities Commission and so
utilities at least ever Source uh
determined that it was probably not an
area of focus I I will say uh and you
know much kudos to Unitil for
structuring a um a a good uh filing that
was able to get puc approval and in some
ways showing a pathway forward for other
utilities about how to to move forward
on this I I will say that eversource is
actively uh considering
multiple potential investment
opportunities under this and obviously
changes to the statute would have a
chilling effect on that as I previously
testified okay seeing no further
questions I'll uh turn next and thank
you Mr Lata turn next to clean energy
New Hampshire and invite Sam Evans Brown
back up to talk with us
to give us uh his perspective on this
proposed
legislation thank you Mr chair thank you
members of the committee the hour is
getting late uh and so I'll try to be
brief uh I think probably much of the
substance of this is already been hashed
out but i' I'd maybe like to try to pull
the camera up a little bit to a slightly
more 30,000 foot view of this particular
issue um Clin H is neutral on the bill
as as introduced I think that some of
the questions about how to
operationalize this are are worthy ones
I think the concept though is a is a
good one the two studies that I think
the committee should really turn their
attention to that have been filed at the
Public Utilities Commission are the
value of distributed energy resources
study and more importantly I think the
locational value of distributed
generation study which which came out
prior to the VD report um the the VD
report really is the justification for
the net metering tariffs that we have
today it essentially says that
smallscale distributed gener connected
to the distribution grid as opposed to
the bulk transmission grid has extra
value and that's why we give extra
compensation to net metered projects the
locational value study sort of you know
further elaborates on on that and says
on certain spots on the grid there's
even more value to generation because
you have circuits that are stressed you
have load Pockets you have you know
upcoming utility Investments that can be
deferred with an investment in
generation as opposed to just more uh
sort of uh uh you know substations and
poles and wires um the the I think the
the Nuance here that's interesting is
that uh currently a third-party Merchant
developer has no insight into which are
those circuits that would benefit from
additional generation they have no way
to monetize that additional benefit on
those additional circuits and when you
read the you know I apologize for the
acronym with the lvg the locational
value study what you see is that there's
a huge amount of discrepancy between the
value on different circuits there are
circuits in which additional generation
doesn't provide any additional value and
there there are circuits on which
additional generation provides huge
amounts of value um other states have
have recognized this and they have
created tariffs they have created
programs they've created they've created
price signals that allow you to get
additional compensation if you're
putting generation close to load on on
circuits that are stressed uh so in
particular Vermont has a very you know
much publicized battery storage uh
incentive and and essentially you get
paid extra your incentive is doubled if
you do battery storage that is
controlled by the utility and is on a
circuit that is that is has been
identified as a circuit in need of
additional support um and so I think uh
while while the specific language of the
bill and I think the the questions about
how you would operationalize this and
what it means are all valid questions um
it's a really important idea that there
are currently uh uh elements of the
value stack that's been alluded to
multiple times that that third-party
developers have no way to access uh it's
it's a it would be a valuable discussion
with our Utility Partners as to how you
could structure some sort of rate or
tariff or program that would create the
price signal that's being asked for here
um and and I'm hopeful that despite the
disagreement between the community power
Coalition and eversource about this
specific Bild that that's a conversation
that we all can have
excellent thank you very much questions
for Mr Evans
Brown well seeing none thank you we'll
close our public hearing today by
hearing from Unitil Alex Oma is going to
come up and talk to us um about his
perspective on this bill and having been
he in um intimately involved with the
Unitil
project that Mr hearnen referred to
earlier he can answer a lot of questions
that we might have so Mr
Romera welcome don't forget to turn on
the
mic I see that now thank you very much
uh I'll do the best to answer the
questions as I can for the record as
noted my name is alak oma I'm here to
represent Unitil and our ears are
collectively burning we've been
discussed quite a bit here and recognize
why uh wanted to talk a little little
bit about uh our project as it stands uh
clarify a few points in regards to what
the value of the Kingston solar array is
for our customers and talk a little bit
about uh some of the dockets and
adjudication proceedings that are
happening around this because I think
it's
relevant uh first and foremost when we
talk about the value to our customers
and the cost benefit analysis that
happened with our solar array and for
anyone here who isn't familiar with our
solar array was approved ground broke on
it last year we're expecting it to come
online later this year uh the cost
benefit analysis specifically was
looking to the value that the de project
provides to our overall distribution
system uh we talked about there's been a
lot of talk today about uh reimbursement
and compensation uh this is really an
offset I think that's the right way to
think about what the value of this
project is for our customers because of
the energy that is being generated ated
by this project is localized it does
give us the opportunity to lower the
overall transmission costs that we have
and lower the distribution costs
effectively because it is part of our
distribution system this de project will
allow us to operate our distribution
system more efficient more efficiently
what that means is that the system as a
whole will lower costs for all Unitil
customers that is all Unitil electric
customers in New Hampshire universally
it benefits all customers whether they
are on any kind of Supply if they're on
default Supply if they're on Supply from
a third party provider the system itself
lowers other costs and that provides the
benefit for our customers that's
different than saying that it provides a
level of reimbursement for us as a
utility I think that's an important
distinction to make for this
group the other point I wanted to make
is since there's been a lot of talk
about this idea of load settlement I
know that eversource referenced this but
there is an active docket before the New
Hampshire Public Utilities Commission
that is looking at all of these Concepts
this idea of load settlement
compensation for thirdparty net meter
providers power generators I believe its
number is
22660 and it's going to get underway in
uh February of this year and all of
these pieces are going to be reviewed as
part of that docket and from Till's
perspective that docket is the
appropriate place for all these
conversations to
occur finally the third question that uh
I wanted to raise was uh it has been
asked a few times here will this
potential uh addition to the statute uh
potentially hinder future projects on
behalf of utilities uh from uni Till's
perspective being the utility that has
gone through this project uh we're
looking at this language and we're
saying yes that is a
possibility uh overall like we had said
because there is this docket happening
with uh the puc
2260 uh a concern that one might have
would be that adding this language to
this particular docket would create a
situation where this issue could get
relitigated over and over as part of all
future proceedings when another project
comes before again there is a path right
now before the Pu to have this Con
concept of load generation be looked at
uh adding it to this statute as well
could potentially mean that it gets you
know if you if you don't like how that
came out it could come up again and
again so I think it's important to raise
that potential issue as well so overall
uh wanted to had a hunch our solar array
might come up today as part of this bill
so wanted to come in and uh give you our
perspective on those pieces and answer
any questions you might have
thank you Alec and I apologize for
mispronouncing your name as Alex that's
quite all right I didn't look closely
enough at your card to see that it was
Alec so I have a question I think I
understood you to say that open dockets
at the currently at the Pu on many of
these subjects like load estimation and
settlement processes and data sharing
Etc might make passing this legislation
pre premature you did not indicate on
your card though whether you support or
uh oppose this legislation or are
neutral yeah we are neutral on this
legislation we came here from an
educational perspective uh as we
expected our solar array was likely
going to be a topic of conversation here
and we would have some points of
clarification following testimony and
that's why we're here and that's what
we're
saying perfect thank you representative
Harrington has a question thank Youk Tak
my question as far as your project in
Kingston goes is it uh accurate to state
that you went through all this analysis
on reduction of load and transmission
cost and so forth and then those results
were unique to that particular project
at that location and wouldn't
necessarily would apply to a different
project 100 miles away I think it's
accurate to say that location of a
specific project would be a factor with
any such development um going forward
each individual project should probably
be looked at at a case-by case basis I
think that's a prudent approach for any
distribution project thank
you further questions representative
Corman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr
Amira
uh I'm sorry but I was a little unclear
on on how it would be that this bill
could have projects being relitigated
can you go into that in a little more
detail what what what the steps would be
why that would happen yeah absolutely
and to be fair we found the language in
the statute a bit Broad we're just
acknowledging that it appears to have a
lot of parallels with an active docket
before the Pu right now so in looking at
that uh adding specific language to this
particular docket could create the
potential where these topics then get
reviewed on a repeated basis as opposed
to in a separate docket which then has
an order and declares what that process
would be going forward a docket has an
end point a statute can be reviewed in
perpetuity
good point further
questions seeing none it looks like
we're done thank you uh Mr Oma for being
here is there anyone in the audience who
would like to make a comment or give
some brief testimony who' forgot to
submit a pck
card okay seeing none I guess we're done
so we're going to close the public
hearing on House Bill 406 FN and that
pretty much concludes our business for
today I will remind members that we will
start a executive session on three bills
tomorrow morning promptly at
9:00 and after that we'll have public
hearings on four additional bills over
the course of the rest of the day so
thank you for your work today and we'll
see you all tomorrow excuse me Mr chair
yes uh Tom uh representative PL
representative PL blue sheet
if you'd like to read the blue sheets
please
do okay on the blue sheets today I'll
spill
189 zero Pro zero
against House Bill
221 one in favor seven
opposed House Bill
224 one in favor seven
opposed House Bill 4 4
36 uh there was none in favor none
opposed same with House Bill 627 none in
favor none oppose our last bill House
Bill
460 was one in favor none
opposed e